welcome everybody to the bullet chess
championship presented by sig
grandmaster robert hess alongside me
today as always is grand master amman
hamilton
amman we're in store for some exciting
matchups today it is the semis it will
then be followed by the finals
how are you feeling about today's action
well hello robert hello everyone in the
chat watching
welcome to what should be a really
exciting day of chess and
robert i think we're in for a treat
because we actually do have
the top four seeds you know that started
off this bullet chess championship
uh in the the semi-finals today so i
don't think you could
ask for any better matchups on paper no
i don't think you can and there are four
players competing for the grand prize
but let's remind everyone of the format
for those you
who are new here it started as a 12
player bracket
it is now down to the final four the
matches have
a timer of 30 minutes total there will
be a break
at the 15 minute point a half time break
for the players to get refreshed
gather their bearings and try to figure
out what to do next it is one minute
zero second increment the whole way
through and if there is a tie we
actually saw this yesterday
there will be a sudden death tie break
where the winner of the tie break game
moves on to the next round and amman now
that we see the prize fund we've been
talking about it day after day but
it's starting to feel within their grasp
look at this prize fund
if you lose the semi-final match up you
still get 2 500
yeah just by uh you know as long as
people show up today robert they're
they're already punching that 2500 check
uh into their account so not too shabby
and though that's just if you lose
obviously it's only
up from there as we see the grand prize
of ten thousand dollars for first place
a cool 10k check for some bullet chest
that sounds easier than it is because
let's look at this bracket and remind
everybody of how we got here look at the
superstars
in this field alireza ferrugia had to
knock super grand master
vladislav artemyev we saw andrew tang
storm back from the edge of defeat
to beat nihal siren of course daniel
nardiski had the walk over against eric
hansen
and then hikaru nakamura did crush
arjunara gassing the final score was not
indicative of arjun's play but hikaru
was really feeling it yesterday and
amman today we start with
dania versus andrew the right side of
that bracket
you know i'm gonna ask it yesterday i
held off but now the question must be
asked
who's winning this match-up well i think
uh
one thing that nobody will be surprised
to hear
which is going to be a major factor is
daniel naradiski has
not played a game in this championship
so far robert
um he he seated in obviously didn't get
those quote unquote warm-up matches
obviously a player that you might expect
to find in the semifinals regardless so
when you talk about players that deserve
to be here he's on the top of your list
but
i still think that that's going to be
relevant here tang sort of got those
jitters out of the way we saw him
make an insane comeback during his last
match
he's now said that he's going to go fix
some things he got to see
what it was like to enter a match with a
specific strategy
and whether that worked or not so i
think the experience is going to give
andrew the edge in this particular
format i agree with that
i think that's a big factor and well
daniel will need to replicate nihal
success from the early stages of
yesterday's match trying to get andrew
out of his comfort zone that opening
line wasn't working andrew had a break
he fixed it
but it's clear that andrew likes his
systems and so we'll see if donna's
going to be able to handle that
and we want to give a big shout out to
our presenting partner for the bullet
chess championship
susquehanna international group is a
global quantitative
trading firm that use strategic games
like chess to improve their
decision-making skills and one of the
largest
proprietary trading firms in the world
so shout out to sig thank you for making
this possible and without further ado
let's bring the players
on screen because that's what everybody
wants to see
is andrew tang dania naraditsky
this is for a shot in the finals the 10
first place prize amman i'm gonna go
with donya he hasn't played
i just have the sense that he really
wants this
and donna is one of the absolute best
bullet players on the planet
and when he wants it he's not streaming
he's
fully focused i'm going to give donya
the slight nod in this one
yeah and i don't blame you the the thing
about narediski is i feel like
uh it's almost like his ceiling is a
little bit higher than tangs when he's
on
boy is he on it feels like every move
that he plays in half a second
is like a winning tactic and you spend
time trying to out calculate daniel
nerdiski yeah i mean it's pretty much
like you're playing hikaru as the
players are off
and wow look how closely these guys are
raided robert
and i was about to say the same and look
at the scotch we have a four night
scotch
donut going back to his childhood and
just playing simple positions trying to
outplay
andrew i guess in these end games where
you have the better pawn structure
yeah and you know people that are
familiar with this variation will know
that it definitely screams
sort of equality pretty drawish but
that's when you're playing longer time
controls in bullet remember anything can
happen and those double pawns isolated
pawns at that
on the f file are definitely going to
play a part here and i like what darn it
done rook c1 he played
pawn c4 he brings knight into c5 on the
dark squares and he's just rerouting the
knight maybe
a5 to hit the c6 pawn and that's the
problem with knights and bullets they go
all over the place
they do the the move c5 is gonna happen
here which is really good for
andrew it's going to open up a b file or
ponzi and center are going to start
storming through so i think that move is
really important
and look at the clock by the way andrew
playing at lightning speed dania a
little slower maybe it's the lack of
practice you mentioned it that darning
did not have a match yesterday and so
that could be
actually affecting him in this one right
and don't touch that a pawn that's
poisoned there as bishop b5 check will
pick up the rook
um he's not going to grab that instead
he's looking to kick these out but
knight b3 with the fork
wow that's unbelievable and the fact
that he didn't go for it
right away and the reason he didn't is
bishop e3 there's rookie two now whereas
when the bishop was on g4
there would be no pin so he actually
mapped this out perfectly
rook be one member rookie two check you
win the rook on b1 that's game
so impressive so impressive because
that's definitely something that daniel
was considering as you mentioned but
keep in mind that bishop on the g4
square stops the exact move that was
needed
to make that whole tactic possible yeah
donya in the zone i'm looking at him on
camera we see him often on camera when
he's streaming
he looks pretty relaxed and this is just
the start of the match both players
calmly getting settled here
andrew's wearing his c9 jersey he was
proud of that yesterday the whole team
is supporting him the esports
organization and look at this position
ripped open knight takes h4 the h5 pawn
is gone let's come back to f5 but bishop
d3 trying to move the knight from the
defense of the g7 square
yeah bishop d3 this looks great for
white already he's gonna hit that deep
on knight c3 coming next long castle and
that
d-pawn's a goner great opening for
andrew yeah the knight on b4 is awkward
because i could stay there for now but
a3 is going to kick
is he sacking on c3 that may be his hope
but this doesn't look like enough
compensation
no because there's no knight a2 and 86
just drops the deep on here
it basically if you could get that
knight into the c4 square it might be
some hope but the fact that deepon
dropped i i don't i can't believe in
this
oh so it's like a great game from andrew
chang thus far look at the rooks
need open space to thrive the kingdom c7
is safe for the moment of d5 there'll be
knight e5 so
i like the way don is trying to defend
but he's down 10 seconds
and in exchange yeah and he's setting up
queen e3 maybe not letting that king run
to a7 where it wants to go
let me donate got the king there then i
can come to c5 this move d5
by white a few moves ago that gives the
knight the dark squares and wealth
there's a queen hang and a resignation
and andrew tang evens it up one piece
yeah i mean right when you're almost
complimenting black's position he's
right back in the game
sort of forgets that the rooks they
cover a lot of space laterally and
across that fourth rank drops the entire
queen
so now we're level one to one and we're
back to a position that i think we've
seen andrew in quite a bit in his match
and he's playing the french defense
which is this is a better version of
french in terms of bullet play because
that bishop on b7 actually has
life right on the long diagonal but
white objectively is doing well here i
believe you can just play king to b1 the
g2 pawn is untouchable you give that
pawn up open the g5 gophering chuck
mining attack
yeah there's no way you touched that
pawn here however
ideas like bishop takes a3 definitely in
the air that queen is
you know nearly trapped robert in the
middle of this game yeah it's pretty
funny thankfully they can slide back to
the e8 square oh
not anymore after bishop to b5 spoke too
soon
but you called it that's exactly where
that queen needed to go but andrew a
little bit lackadaisically he's gonna
have to give up
a whole piece here and he's just
grasping at straws
yeah even queen b5 that's great move
because that way you protect against the
attack you try to trade queens you did
just win a piece
and that should be the game and uh it's
kind of hard to point out now but the
move bishop g5 earlier
open up the defense of the d4 pawn and
that's what allowed donnie to trap the
queen
and there's rook before here so a nice
tactic actually by andrew
and uh that's that's probably as good of
a position as andrew could have asked
for
and donya is sloped in the starts these
games but he is
wicked fast in time trouble he needs to
watch out for these pawns storming down
the
queen side but i think with the knight
over there he's able to stop it rook to
a1 king to d3 king to c4
he should be able to get those pawns i
think so but
what what black might be trying to do
here is give up those pawns in exchange
for getting the king over and get some
quick moves in
yeah that makes sense and here's the
king to d65 maybe
okay well it's a time scramble actually
don is ahead in the clock he started
behind
but he's moving those pieces very
quickly having the extra piece is very
helpful
throwing a check here and there and oh
it's almost made against that kid yeah
yeah and just uh dania is so aware of
when he can pre-move and when he can
and he's going to be going for some sort
of stalemate here but i don't think he's
going to be able to get it
i can barely look at the moves as
they're happening and daniel
wins that game on the clock but also on
the board what a back and forth match
we're seeing already
and this is what we expect from two
people 3 300
rated on chess.com and they have those
ratings for a reason as we see this
knight c6 uh opening here this sort of
chagoran stuff where you want to play
bishop f5 knight b4 really quickly
yeah it's like a mix of the baltic and
the chagoran and it's kind of awkward
honestly because the pawn c7
is stuck that you'd rather have on c5
and take in the center but right now
andrew doing everything perfectly taking
over the semi-open b5 can't push b6
because the knight and c6 will hang so
daniel will have to go knight a5 at some
point soon
yeah absolutely queen d5 he's looking
for a trade but it's not going to happen
before b5 i knew this is going to happen
oh pc4
saved by queen c4 and now b6 okay
wow queen to a4 what weird play
i mean this is not like
[Laughter]
can't recommend this in standard chess
but in bullet chest go for it
yep i mean he's moved that queen like
eight times in a row and he still has a
fine position
yeah i mean the whole rest of the game
is gonna determine when is white gonna
take on b6 and now you take with the c
pawn so you don't lose the c7 pawn with
a rook c3 next and
black is still fighting here yep
and 95 and i guess it's going to be
taken okay but now black's pawn
structure is worse to open c5 knight to
d5 with tempo
it's starting to look very dangerous for
black but don't forget the f2 pawn
exactly even sat on d5 potentially
that's what i was thinking i
i guess it didn't really lead to
anything after king h2 but
something to think about for sure how
about the knight being stuck on a5 can
oh
as soon as i say it
what a heroic knight oh my god now on if
you ever have a bad piece contact robert
has he'll he'll get it out of there for
you
yeah i'll just mention it and then it'll
improve i guess i'm like a genie
and here we see the pieces getting
traded off dining on eight seconds
though so tang ahead in the clock but
dino with the extra material
definitely advantage white here knight
is so good king is safe
it all comes down to pre-moves there's
knight g6 oh my gosh the fight that did
not just lose the queen there danya
trying his best but andrew's too fast
queen of seven
look at him go just back and forth he's
not gonna be any other moves
if i'm andrew i need to attack the rook
there it is there it is
and then he gets it that's all you need
because that honestly
that's a really good strategy from
narrative when you're when you're that
far down on time against the player as
strong as andrew tang
you have to go for stuff like that you
just have to move and andrew wasn't
pre-moving we saw artemia of lose
because he was pre-moving
a little bit too soon and if donnie
played a rook takes e7 or some kind of
tricky move taking the knight sacrifice
and the queen
and andrew was pre-moving he would have
been trouble speaking of trouble look at
that king on h7
i'm looking at bishop g5 rook to e1 type
of ideas
that looks dangerous for black here 100
rookie one you're thinking about knight
e5
um but andrew is is holding this
position and you know if he can get some
trades the end game looks fantastic for
black
oh yes the bishop pair looked great look
at the c7 pawn though that's where the
queen went to g3
and i'm waiting for something to e5
there's something the knight is now
named something and look at this the
queen back to g8
down is storming forward here the c7
pawn is weak
and just goes knight back to f3 to take
the pawn but gives up that central pawn
in return
yeah this bishop h3 stuff on tap which
is why he went back to g3
like h2 interesting yeah bishops my
goodness
dinos pieces are going backwards andrews
were perfectly placed but then he goes
bishop back to g7
and all of a sudden donna's pieces are
coming out that's the move that you need
though queen takes a2
now you can be a little more comfortable
going for trades because you know you've
got these two connected pass bonds
ready to roll down the board and what a
move h5 is
the position was about to open up and
andrew says no let's close this thing up
and unless donna can get another piece
into the attack
he's really not doing anything against
that black king and such
good play by andrew look how he
re-routed his bishop to c6
immediately gets on the long diagonal
trading to this end game two bishops two
connected passports gotta be winning
absolutely now he's up two pawns it's
obstacle bishops that gives white some
chances
in over the more classical chess but not
in bullet with the extra time for black
yeah i mean the the extra time for black
but it's it's shrinking
yeah a2 though look at that bishop to c3
rook
you can throw in a rook at six oh that's
a queen
oh and that's the problem oh oh oh and
unfortunately for donya that's in
andrew's favor
and now it's about to be three to two
andrew can pre-move his way to victory
here
and take that bishop okay isn't it i
wouldn't take the bishop actually
but yeah you notice in that position g3
was played by white that's to make sure
that
hey if there's a stalemate at least i'm
making it possible with move g3 i don't
want any pawn moves in the position
and now we get to game number six it is
a lead
for andrew i like this queen f5 line in
bullet perhaps white
it not anticipating that you can win
your opponent's queen but look at this
this is getting really hectic here
if a4 wow the queen comes to a5 is this
some kind of
known line i don't know if it's known
a known line or not but it's becoming
known to us right now i wonder if we'll
see this again
in this match usually players repeat
lines uh in bullet just how to have it
well i love the look of the knight in f4
because it attacks the g2 bishop and it
steals his e2 pawn
now white has an isolated queen palm
which isn't too fun no longer is a
license look at this as soon as i
mentioned
a problem it gets fixed i should just
someone should hire me
yeah yeah i actually i'm a little broke
robert so if you don't mind touching on
that subject
oh well we'll uh we'll leave that to a
later conversation i guess
uh and here the queen b5 is under attack
the a3 pawn is falling knight takes e5
next to win the pawn e5
yeah so trading into a better ending but
how much better because even material
yeah i think black should play move like
g5 here and get the king out yeah like
g5 fixes these pawns obviously you need
the space for your king
and these pawns for white look very weak
look how passive those rocks are
yeah those rooks just defending the
pawns there and look at black putting
the rooks on the fifth rank the kings
coming in
at somewhat f5 here it is just trying to
move your past pawns
yep takes takes and i mean you've got
this past e pawn but
i would say that as far as pass pawns go
you'd rather have the pawn on
on the outside i think donnie missed a
chance to put a rook on the
fourth rank and get his team to g5 so
he's he's shuffling the rooks around
which is smart
and e5 was really good to cover the
sixth rank and now blocks off
pawn and he can target that he wants to
trade a pair of rooks desperately making
it so much easier
and donnie at some point he's going to
bring the away rook right he's putting
the nearer rook and then he brings the a
rook in
check okay but there's going to be a
rook f7
i feel like there's got to be some draw
for white but rook
e7 such a great move oh my gosh look at
this no king moves so the rook and the
hs we're gonna fight but look at the
time
these guys are just so fast it takes the
rook
unbelievable he wins oh my goodness and
you see that heavy breath from done he
wasn't breathing all game
he takes it on the clock wow and there's
just that
that recognition strong bullet players
will know exactly
when you play for the position like hey
do i pre-move this just
like an insane person don't care where
my pieces go or
do i maybe try to catch my opponent's
crazy pre-move just once spend an extra
you know second
and then i have easy pre-moves with an
extra rook so it's
man it's that toss-up i don't i never
know how to judge that situation
and we just saw in the ticker they
played about 3 000 games and daniel has
a lead
of maybe 150 i couldn't do the math
quickly enough but either way these two
are very experienced against one another
and as you see here 15 33 and a half to
13 84 and a half that is
a ridiculous quantity of games and
speaking of ridiculous this attack looks
very dangerous i think that the queen
could have went to d3 earlier instead of
putting the knight on
to g6 but either way knight to h5 the
rook on the e file the light squares
everything is seemingly problematic for
all nineteen seven
move to start with and this game's over
after queen g6 yes because bishop g6
check and the queen h7 will be a mate
okay just making sure he's playing the
move that he should play i actually
think he was thinking of b3 there and
bishop b2 on the long diagonal oh that
makes a lot of sense
yeah oh yeah bishop before f6 pre-move
queen g7 actually or no no don't prove
queen g7 because if he takes your bishop
but
you haven't made on h8 or g7 so you
don't need a free move
incredible and that that was just a
crush i mean we barely finished talking
about the last game and this one's over
andrew goes for his kind of signature
line he loves these
same-ish variations these f3 bononis he
always goes for these types of positions
and donya is trying to use this
tactically to his advantage but actually
andrew's been the quicker player
in the earlier stages of the game so i'm
liking andrew's position this far
and i think that this gives him good
chances yeah the fact is that knight
doesn't have g4 although typical idea
you go knight d3 say hey bishop d3 yell
give you a pawn but
andrew he's he's attuned to that because
he says rook c4 and now that knight's
trap
yeah the nice trap of that 984 is also
kind of trapped so he
seems like daddy got away with one there
it seemed like he should have lost a
piece but
it was hard to figure out especially in
the bullet game and now knight to e4
very
good move f5 can be played next thematic
pawn sacrifice i've seen levana ronin do
that many times
and you give up on e5 then play f5 and
just try to push your d-pawn
attack on the f-file f6 g6 where queen
f7 check was available just a moment ago
this has to be over in bullet there's
just no way it's just done right now
because after fg is queen of seven
queens you should have made it here at
gf and then
what's new when you play d6 there's h5
hanging
okay well dino's not checkmated so
that's a good start for him
and now there's no rook d7 or rook f7
and now you cut the rook off and
quit d7 would have won a piece that was
a nice attack just to queen that pawn
there he's doing it to slow 896 but he's
going to get this done
100 this is over yeah now he's up in
exchange and that black king is about to
be checkmated
mm-hmm for p7 b7 that's a check from c7
not nothing too scary though
where's the knockout this gets
frustrating when you should be winning
in a million ways
and yet there's no checkmate annoying
he's up a lot of time which is why he's
probably not panicking right now
otherwise i would be take take and the
queen
yep now if only that pawn wasn't there
or something you could get white to
pre-move
uh you know promotion to a queen for a
stalemate but
yeah that would be something that would
be actually fantastic if that were
available
unfortunately for don yeah it was not
and amman we're going to break
it is tied four to four this is even as
it gets
and my question for you is what should
each side change the action has happened
so quickly that i haven't really had the
time to process it so i'm gonna let you
have the floor before we go to break
i can't believe that was 15 minutes that
that time just absolutely disappeared
that was the quickest first half of any
match
that i think we've commentated so far at
least for me um andrew and meredith are
currently
neck and neck especially in the time
scrambles i don't know who's gonna win
uh even when it's two seconds a piece
these guys are so fast
so evenly matched that i don't think
anything separates them there but what
we have seen and you mentioned it
tang the faster player it seems early on
and then naradiski starts to ramp up to
speed so if you're andrew
i think you're feeling pretty confident
with your earlier play
and you have to start trusting that that
same stuff that's making you play
quickly at the beginning of the game
trust it in the middle and towards the
end because
when andrew gets a time advantage he's
putting games away against nerditsky
yeah i think that's a good take and i
will add that this benoni that we just
saw
i wouldn't go back to that if i'm done i
would change that up that seemed too
much in andrew's comfort zone he played
a pretty perfect game honestly
and so i think the openings could use a
little tweaking they have the break we
will take one as well
everybody you will not want to miss the
continue action from this bullet chess
championship presented by sig i got into
playing poker in college
and really liked it but never considered
i could make a career out of it
until jeffy ass came and gave a talk at
harvard jeff explained that
yes you can actually use gaming skills
for your career and for something to do
on a day-to-day basis
which was exciting at the time i thought
it was really cool we can pretty much
guarantee you that we'll give you the
best education you will be taught all
that we know
in a very professional manner by expert
teachers and
you're going to be mentored and i like
to think that there's no other place
where you can get as much mentorship as
you can
at susquehanna i think that the main
thing that everybody has in common is
a sense of competitiveness and interest
in in gaming and
strategy in general i would say you're
you're playing a game as a career
it's very satisfying to me that we've
been able to employ so many people
give them not just an opportunity to
make a lot of money but to be with the
smartest people in the world
and to have a lot of fun and make a lot
of friends and create a culture
of reason
[Music]
before we get back to the second half of
this match between dania naradick and
andrew tang we want to remind everybody
that tomorrow
there will be the bullet chest
championship all-star edition
and you see your favorite personalities
these big streamers
on screen in front of you i'm on i'm
looking at that four or five matchup
that is the one that
everybody wants to see yeah this is
really exciting
i think the all-star it just sort of
caps off a week of bullet and i like the
format of just having
you know whatever you're interested in
chess.com's got everything bullet
covered
your favorite personalities getting
involved because it's nice to watch you
know the top players in the world play
which we're
watching right now but it's also nice to
check in on those personalities and that
should be a very uh exciting event there
see maurice ashley
and uh tanya well that's a gm i am
match-up in the first round
that's because it's bullet ratings and
some players less experienced in the
bullet time patrol the players that
we're watching right now certainly are
not
inexperienced we have daniel nareditsky
we have andrew tang they played about 3
000 games against one another
on the chess.com server and countless
more across the other so
i mean this is just an epic match up and
we have game nine underway donna starts
with
again the four knights yeah this has
been a go-to
uh must be a little bit to do and
careful
h3 knight takes f3 is a easy move to
fall into in bullet but i think he's
just going for this opening because it's
kind of easy to pre-move and just get
the quick moves early on
well it was quick moves then diner sat
for a thing just not trying to blunder
this h3 move
and now he's down on the clock by four
seconds yeah what what a nice pin right
this bishop on g4 can't be attacked by
h3
and uh he's just going for it with g5
here
wow and that's a very dangerous decision
because look at the f5 square
just queen f2 here there's no attack for
black so i think this was misjudged
yeah the king h2 bishop h3 at some point
will happen at least king h2 rook f5
bishop h3 and i mean this is all
naradisky it looks like and if you ever
play gtx h4 bishop h3 is the response
not even the recapture so he takes in g5
if f takes rook f7 just trade off the
rooks your king is safe
those g and h pawns are in trouble the
knight in h7 is kind of trapped
so i really like diamond's position yeah
and there he goes with uh
rook down he's going to trade everything
there is g4 here so that's an important
move rook d7
yes and there comes g7 there and if g4
then bishop moves and the h5 pawn is a
little bit loose
but the piece comes to g5 yeah knight g5
in the way
so if this king gets over to like e7 i
think this is very manageable for andrew
and knight against bishop it's just a
bullet thing
sometimes you love the knight even when
it shouldn't be better
yeah the knight coming to e5 it's a dark
square it's light square bishop so c5 is
going to be played
just trying to give the knight fewer
safe squares you don't want that outpost
for well black wants the alpha as white
as i'm going to give an e5 check b7 is
falling the e pawn has passed
who's better here rook d7 was the piece
and daniel was ahead on time
and that was the difference maker there
absolutely like if
if black's ahead on time here the extra
piece i this is still a game
but no he was he was down way too much
time
and he doesn't have any any stalemate
tricks or anything like that and that's
grand masterful technique right there
with rookie five checks seeing that you
could trade off the pieces
and then you'd win the palm on the light
square so right now we go to game
10 where donald the black pieces has
less space with that moroxy bind kind of
structure well not really moroccan
because it's a c
pawn but that bind with c4 and e4 and
look at andrew go just pushing that h1
up the board
yeah well they're both doing the exact
same strategy but on opposite sides the
h-pawn's running and so is that a pawn
so
naradiski's pretty much got the same
idea knight takes b3
how is this going to be matt wow that
was a really sick tactic there by danya
and andrew completely missed it
otherwise he would take on b2 with the
queen
now there's still some attacking
potential but queen f6 trading the quiz
no more no this is just a great game for
danya
yeah this should be enough um knight can
obviously come back to
d5 and hit the rook but this is he's in
full survival mode here
what's the material count of full extra
exchange and now a
pawn in addition to the exchange so this
is just
dania up on the clock if i'm andrew you
don't
resign just yet because they're still
almost 11.5 minutes in the match
but it's getting close to that territory
where you think about resigning earlier
yeah that hit this is a position i might
consider giving up
yeah king h that's it's always sad when
the point just put the king in the
corner and you're using g5 and your
knights yeah
about to be kicked at f6 and it's close
right you're like one move away from
making that work exactly
this isn't doing it no not good enough
uh there might be a knight f7
move to look for which is why you played
rook fade but dania
didn't blunder that rather he said okay
let's simplify that actually makes my
life easier
and there we see a resignation and there
would have been a cool pre-move
anticipation if he went knight f7 the
rook took if he gone rook f7 and if
daniel pre-moved rick takes up seven
which he wasn't
but you can just try to go for
last-second tricks here and by the way
tang's rating has gone below
20 300 not 23 i just way above that and
so
they're not gonna be too bothered
they'll get back over 3300 and you know
give it a bit of time but right now
donya up six to four and now with the
white piece in this game
steals the pawn on c5 and looks great
for dining once again
yeah it looks solid here however
sometimes what happens in bullet because
i know because it happens to me
you you get sidetracked trying to trap a
queen like that on the side of the board
you waste a lot of time
and sometimes if you commit too hard
then you realize you're just down on
time and you're not
actually trapping it in the end yes and
queen c2 is mate so you do not want to
fall for that he just drops his bishop
back for testing a5
oh gosh a threesome you're going to a4
just try to kick that bishop out so the
queen comes to c3 and
i think a4 queen takes b4 dania figures
his king is not getting checkmated so
that's a good start
bishop a4 is really key there stopping
the advance
and wow he's trading everything
well he's up material oh okay he he
was not losing a piece because after
bishop sticks to rook and d7 was under
attack
plants the bishop on d6 if gf3 gf3 the
g7 pawn's a problem so that's why andrew
is keeping that pawn on g4
yeah this is intricate stuff here is
queen d3 is looking for a trade up on
time it's neridisky and opposite bishops
if you're up on time you're the big
favorite yeah this is well done by donya
he
lost most of his advantage over the
board in fact black is probably better
but he's leading on the clock but look
at andrew cutting into that time deficit
yeah really impressive maybe e5 as well
there we go finally
so he's got to start running these pawns
up the board f4 notice how he's
advancing dark square pawns with a light
squared bishop
and that was really good decision by
downing to sacrifice the bishop it's a
time scramble right now and
they're about even on the clock but this
g-pawn is too easy to push
i love the technique by tang my goodness
that was so impressive he got everything
on his square where he was defended
don't play quintix he do
there you go that was nice try by donny
but tang
he really bounced back in that game
because early on he was down a pawn and
looked like he was in big trouble
he ends up creating complications and he
has the mouse speed
he definitely does i mean that's not
something that either player in this
match
are lacking and andrew look how quickly
he got castle this time he said you know
what
that whole h-pawn thing what happened
last time i got killed with knight takes
b3 on the queen side
not happening again yeah he realizes
it's not necessary to gain an advantage
and
i'm looking for f5 at some point he
takes an a4 here
so if you trade everything on a4 you
turn on g7 then some kind of f5 looks
scary
for the black king and we're seeing just
that he goes f5
first so knight e5 look at that move
you're trying to close down as much of
the position
as possible the bishop on b1 not useful
for the attack just yet
and that's why you didn't take on f5
because the bishop would have had long
range
on the b1 h7 diagonal wow what a move
i i'm wondering what the plan is here
okay so queen d4 check i don't like
moving the queen away from the king's
safety i thought maybe queen to g5
right it was a bit safer but either way
he's holding on
trades and queens wow he just grabs a
pawn reggae
send that rook right back rook f8 the
rook style went from
defense into offense so dania saving his
king but not his clock
and he's hitting the rook on d1 there's
no queen takes g6 but there is queen e6
and now he's gone right back
and looking for a four try rook f2
taking advantage of the fact that queen
needs to stay attached to the rook
a2 can be captured right now but he
instead is going back and forth because
of the clock
yeah and that's why white uh in this
case andrew decided to take that rook he
says you know what i'm up on time
this is a potential flag yes and quincy
one queen f4 is will be
very huge to trade the queens off and
now donya is even
on material but don't count out andrew's
chances because of the clock oh not at
all
not the a4 a timely a4 yep
he's gonna he's gonna push the puns on
the king side as well he's gonna grab g6
and this is definitely a win if not on
the board on the clock yeah it looks
like on the board it should still be a
hold because of the dark square bishop
and
don is doing his best but look at how
quick tang is
and you keep in mind that andrew never
made a pre-move where
daniel could have responded with b3 or
c2
without his pre-move catching it or it
being check so pre-move would cancel
that's just
really really good understanding of when
and where you should pre-move in an end
game like that so you don't get cheesed
that situational awareness is essential
well speaking of cheese queen on h5
threatening mate bishop e4 to try to get
the bishop off but then you trade and
then play h6 so there's no checkmate
just yet rook b1
playing on both sides of the board i
really like the start of this game for
dania
and he's about even the clock he needs
to keep pace with andrew
because he's been getting time trolling
andrew's winning the scrambles
yeah it's true one thing that tang's
been doing really really well is staying
up on time even in those tough positions
and look at that grabbing the a2 pawn
and just bringing the bishop back that
outside pass pawn could be huge in this
game
it could well i mean hey keep in mind
guys that a pawn
we'll watch later in this game if that
really really has an effect and knight
takes b7
bishop takes c6 so black is still up a
pawn the pawns aren't the greatest
because they're split on the queen side
and look at the bishops there e4 f4
aiming
towards the black king you have to be
very careful not to
walking sometimes bishop h6 or something
like that exactly and the funny thing
about that rook on v6 is it was guarding
the bishop on f6 which stopped bishop
takes h6 you almost would never expect
that
of rook going from a8 to b8 to b6 and
playing defense
and look at that taking the c3 pawn
there's bishop d4 threats all the
rook just had to come off the board and
the situation is still an extra pawn but
that's not how i see this i see a weak
king for white and a very safe king for
black and queen b8 is gonna be checkmate
if you're not careful
um so black has got to be very very
mindful of that going forward and that
pawn is dangerous now i
would play c6 bishop d4 maybe okay
bishop e4 to protect the pawn
wow queen is coming to b7 i'm guessing
at some point and like i like that move
bishop f4 just try to get rid of that
block bishop is there bishop h3 no
oh there's queen g1 and then that's just
queen g1 oh
that was a missed opportunity there but
he wins the pawn anyway and now he's
arrested for the piece
it's like a full-time scramble but a
tactic is gonna hurt
and that's three in a row for tang and
he takes these seven
six leads and we're learning a lot about
andrew tang even if he's down a couple
games early on maybe not four like he
wasn't nihal sarin
he can bounce back he is a slow starter
but when he gets going
he is nearly impossible to take down
yeah you cannot
pick a favorite out of these two players
it is one of the most
literal coin flip matches that we have
uh possible in this tournament
and don keeps going back to these
positions and there's some tricks here
i'm worried about the white king but g3
such a nice move
trying to play f4 and down he says no
i'm going to plant my knight there first
and if you play f4 keep in mind that e4
pawn behind it suddenly pretty weak and
there you go
take him with check yeah inter mezzo
overlooked i think by andrew
he was fortunate he could take his
d-pawn of work to d8 play rook fd8 and
then your end game is
much better for black this is still
better because the knight on c5
it's kind of an outpost because there's
nothing to attack it with
yeah that's a great point there's no b4
and it also covers d7
so it kind of kneecaps this rook on d6
and careful king f2 rook d6
that e4 square is ready to be jumped in
yeah knight takes e4 for black would be
a great move so rookie's h4 was a
possibility
but probably some crazy rook action rook
takes g6 for white so
he didn't go for it now 94 where's the
king going
oh a2 is falling and then knight c one
check and then the e3 knight is in
trouble so it goes knight g4 but bad
yeah rookie two this is me it's i think
it's force mate
yeah i think oh there's rook d1
oh rick do with 92 check king c2 it's
winning for black but i just don't think
it's made anymore
where's the mate night before rook c1
there's no mate
he's gonna resign that i think rook c1
next
there was keen to be two and the action
would have continued but andrew says i
had enough of that it is seven
seven two minutes 50 seconds remaining
that means we will get at least two more
games going here
probably even three and this is an even
match on the scoreboard i'm not sure i
like what donnie just did here his king
is a bit exposed
but he's getting the e4 square and i was
really impressed that this worked out
for andrew last time because
i just have the impression this is a
great bullet opening
for white and e4 playing queen f4 the
homeless pin on the fourth rank but look
at that move knight d5 stealing puns h5
traps the bishop
so you take the work on b1 you take on
g6 and we have this material imbalance
where black's king is not very safe
but probably by material blocks should
be doing pretty well and watch out for
the h file though all of a sudden
the the h file is just opening up but
that rookie one move cannot be correct
winning the night oh wow and donya
just grabs his forehead and there are
two oh just over two minutes remaining
we might get two more games i think
we're getting two more games here and
donya needs to at least draw this if he
loses it the match is over
so dino with the black pieces playing
look at this kind of chess here
non-committal bishop one e7 slower
approach
i guess trying to move quickly in the
early stages and then i'll play andrew
later
and that is not a bad strategy at all i
i think at this point you have to
remember that daniel doesn't need to win
this game but he cannot lose it
exactly and he's just going bishop c
look at him going back d5 is protected
risky move f3 your dark squares around
your king could become very vulnerable
now that now the rook on e1 looks like a
magician's like how did he know that
file was going to open up now it looks
well placed
yeah but the queen on b6 knight and e6
speaking of well-placed pieces that 96
in particular looks good knight g5 hits
f3 i go right back and you just need to
figure out that way to you know
you're making progress with black but
where is the knockout coming from
yeah he's got to get like a g6 move in
so that's why he played king h7 to guard
h6 and now some pieces are coming alive
for black
okay actually andrew's the one who's up
on time but black's position looks quite
good here
i like it maybe a b4a5 bishop a6 he
instead
commits over towards the king side and
rookie eight so is there some kind of
night
discoveries not yet not yet talk about
maneuvering look at this game bishop c1
i think that's really good for andrew
just positionally speaking to get those
dark square bishops off the board and
look at this knight and d3 going to e5
there's a c5 square as well
i don't really wait okay there are some
kind of queen h6 check ideas i saw the
eval bar go up so i was like what could
have happened
but that's too hard to find the bullet
game and by the way yeah on the clock
andrew's thinking he plays f4 committal
f5 is working out but he did give up the
e4 square
but daniel walked right into the f5 move
uh it's 14 seconds a piece where is the
ko here
that looks like a good one yeah he goes
rookie six
ninety seven oh and there's 14 seconds
left so if daniel loses this game
it looks like he's about to lose it
looks like andrew tang is making his way
to the final he grabs his head he knows
the situation
and they're gonna get one more game in
but look at andrew takes a drink
he can bask in this last game here
because he can lose it in fact they
agreed on draw because
andrew tang has made his way to
the finals of this bullet chess
championship
and that is uh i mean the draw there
makes sense for both players they all
understood that the match clock had
expired and
opened up a two-game lead for andrew
tank that
that game you called it robert was i
mean that was for all the marbles and
both players knew it i think everyone in
that match was very conscious of the
clock
and about the match situation the entire
time so the comeback from andrew tang
was completed and he maintains his lead
and you could see the celebration he was
pretty calm there but you could tell the
relief and he works his way to the final
cell await the winner of the next match
between hikaru nakamura and ali reza
fruga and for dania niraditsky all you
must be thinking about is what could
have been
you were up by two points in that match
everything was going your way
and then three games in a row won by
andrew tank to turn the tides completely
among you have to be impressed with the
comeback ability of andrew tang
you do and and uh i don't know what you
know what the specific factor was and i
think it would be
almost unfair to attribute it to you
know one thing or
some small thing in this match that was
the difference between these two players
because i think at the end of the day it
just comes down to game day performance
that's an easy thing to say but honestly
i think that andrew tang and daniel
dardisky are
two of the closest match bullet players
like in the world maybe so
always feel like it's a 50 50 calling it
and at the end of the day
it came down to you know one time
scramble that
was the difference the lead for nerdiski
a slightly shorter match and he wins
this thing
and we saw the lifetime records that was
a nerdsy in the lead there but tang said
today is my day
c9 can celebrate their star player and
we are going to take a quick break
because speaking of stars we'll be back
with hikaru nakamura against ali raza
faruja to see
who andrew tang will face in the finals
of this bullet chess championship
presented by sig
[Music]
and we return after that exhilarating
semi-final matchup between
andrew tang and daniel narditzky we have
another great one for you
it is hikaru nakamura it is alireza
faruja and amman i
make you pick somebody every single time
this one is no exception
do you have hikaru the favorite on paper
or do you have alireza the
teenager who is an international
sensation
well i mean first of all we talk about
coin flips i mentioned that
uh we have all four of the best players
in this bullet stress championship right
now this semi-final
no different ali reza has mentioned
himself even in the interview the last
time that
hikaro has gotten the better of him when
he's played him in some of the
semi-finals or even finals before
he's looking for revenge however if
hikaru shows up the way
that he showed up in his previous match
and farouza
shows up the way he did as well i think
hikaru should take this
um that's if they don't change some of
their forms but
uh it all depends robert on who we see
today but you know judging from the past
i'd say hikaru has the edge yeah there
is it did look a bit shaky yesterday but
giving him credit and artemia of credit
he probably had the
toughest opponent in that field or
tamiya of course is a super great master
from russia one of the
most creative players in the planet and
hikara looked absolutely
dominant against arjun arigaisi who
defeated lavon ronin the day before
so i think that either player can win
this matchup i'm also giving the nod to
ikar nakamura
yeah no this is uh this is going to be a
heavyweight matchup though i said it
before i'll say it again it's all about
game day performance like
which version of themselves is going to
show up today as you can see andrew tang
qualified into the finals he awaits he's
probably watching this match
robert with baited breath wondering who
he's going to face and i wonder if he
has any preferences there
uh at this point you're playing a
superstar either way one of the best
players on the planet so i think if
you're andrew tang
just take a breather maybe watch some of
this just see what's going well for
his potential opponent but no matter
what he knows he's in for a tough one
and we're in for a great one because
they're about to begin
we have hikaru nakamura the reigning
bullet champion
we have alireza farouja who could easily
win this thing any year and for years to
come
i'm really excited to mom we can barely
have time to catch our breath because
the action's about to take place
yeah and i mean i i talked about maybe
carl having the slight nod but
i'm starting to wonder if valley res is
maybe wearing a chest bra shirt there
that that's like plus one two hundred
elos isn't that what they say
well maya has been lost in the mail so
no wonder my rating keeps going down
rather than up and
yeah it looks like both players ready
hikaru representing tsm as esports
oregon
where off here your car gets the white
pieces starts at e4 we're getting a
sicilian
that actually surprised me for a bullet
game yep and
wow look at this i think that uh this
position already speaks to
king side pressure and uh looking at the
cam from faroush it almost looks like
he's playing on his phone oh yeah he's
looking down there
he's trying to figure out what's going
on he should look at his king side
because there's a bishop on d3 staring
at the h7 pawn
and black has to go for knight a5 at
some point but instead he throws an h6
this is actually going to be a problem
from queen d3
when you play g60 h6 h61 yeah you're
you're calling it this
is very unpleasant queen d3 aiming at h7
he played f5 to deal with that but it
doesn't really deal with it rook f5 is
such a shaky defense
and you know what doesn't deal with this
look at the clock by the way hikaru has
48 seconds he's up
20 full seconds against ferruja and for
just king is being hunted
yeah not acceptable and look at this i
mean f4
all this but look at the time i feel
like he actually is playing on his phone
no way that that would be pretty absurd
his bishop's getting trapped so
uh that's not seven yeah just ugly full
rook if i'm molly raza
i think i've had enough in game one i'm
moving on to game two yeah
so weird so weird this is not a good
start excuse me not a good start for ali
raza at all
although hikaru is making this a bit
more complicated than probably he needed
to that king on g1
there's some air in front of it and
queen g4 check queen h3 now you can take
on b3 and you take the bishop at the end
it's the time though he's down 20
seconds it's just
never going to be enough yeah that car
very smartly brings that queen back to
d3 how many pounds does he have by the
way it's five pawns
he has enough and black might even be
worse anymore
yeah he's just he has to resign because
of the time but uh honestly i
i probably called that one early based
on the time alone
but even based on the position i think i
called it too early that was really
impressive that
ali reza made a game out of that but
alerissa has a clear blueprint of what
not to do you cannot be down
20 seconds in the clock to the car and
look at a car trading queens here you
have to
because if you move the knight back you
lose d4 b2 if you don't move the night
back you're gonna lose your knight
and we see the trade here and king to d2
play against this french bishop just try
to clog the d4 square
he's gonna kick that knight out and back
to c6 we go and you cannot
easily go bishop to b7 you better bishop
d7 to get out of the pin
that's right but c takes d4 i think you
can get away with that for now he said
he trades the bishops that's the bad
french bishop you might as well get rid
of it
and oh pawn sacrifice that move
that knight on c4 is going to be strong
and
he's allowing knight b2 and just running
his king away is knight e193 the idea
what rook takes three what oh my gosh
he's just blown her piece
no this is something there's something
funny going on with ali reza right now i
i think he's somehow he seems like he's
totally off like slower
not as tactically alert he needs to
regroup and get back in this match asap
with the next game so remind
everybody of what you were saying about
wearing chess bra apparel
and better chess well he's leaning down
so far robert you can't see the shirt
that's that's true sit up straight stop
playing on your phone ali reza let's
let's get some energy in here
do we actually have any confirmation
that he's playing on his computer i mean
we have the fair play cams and
everything so
it does look like he is playing on his
phone the way he's angled this doesn't
look good for his back so
uh you know if any chiropractors are out
there it's okay he's young he'll be all
right but bishop takes h6 is at the
right by the way so watch out for bishop
h6 the bishop is on e7 but i'm looking
for that if the bishop ever leaves the
e7 square
mm-hmm queen b2 you're also looking for
that move uh trying to bait bishop h7
check right and just maneuvering by
hikari he's up 10 seconds
just i mean seriously like every game
he's up 10 seconds like it's no but this
is
it's unacceptable speed i i don't know
why he's he's so slow
a little bit nervous i'm i'm not sure
i've never seen ali reza
really play this way and we're being
told he's playing on his laptop
rather than on his monitor and well
maybe he should go back to the monitor
because
this is not working out from hikaru
jumps to a two-nothing lead and very
impressive play by ikaro
once again in this game look at all the
control over the position
black has no active play and that causes
you to burn time if you're
it definitely does oh look at these
bishops just one bishop
and then two bishops c4 h4 and all of a
sudden he's winning material on that
head
bob from hikaru nakamura yeah he should
be feeling it right now
he's oh i'm like g5 you just take it but
the rook on a5 came to the rescue
so maybe the head bob is a little bit
too soon but once again
the clock is telling the story here the
clock speaks volumes obviously he needed
to take that rook before recapturing on
d4
a little
oh and he resigned wow i don't know if i
would have resigned there because
alvarez only had nine seconds remaining
but that is
a sign of respect like whoa i i'm i
can't get ahead of myself here
oliveriza fights back in that game and
he cuts the deficit in half
and now he has chances once again
amazing how if he lost would have
thought oh this match might be over
right now he's right back in this thing
completely and i mean i've never seen a
head bob go so wrong
oh oh my gosh knight d5 and the e6
yeah that's a piece this is gonna be
like a a masterpiece if this works out
at ef7 king f7 there's i don't see a
follow-up
well it's going to be a masterpiece for
either player if this works out because
if he card defends this that's
also very impressive yeah it looked like
a good sacrifice at first but hikaru's
versus king on f7 i'm sorry i cut you
off there but i
i saw the piece sacrifice and it was
exciting and
honestly it looks like your car is going
to put a knight f5 and there goes your
attack
and it's crazy how it just went from
something to nothing like it now it's
just
there's no threats at all yeah there
probably was something there but you
needed pinpoint accuracy
and all there is it just didn't oh my
gosh yeah
that's angry hikaru yup that's that's
bounced back hikaru
yeah that really is and alvarez needed
that game you know he would have tied up
the match
all the momentum would have swung his
way and now we're getting one of the
nerdiski tank playbook we saw this
we have and i feel like an expert on
this line already especially for bullet
um he's going bishop back to c2 and how
many times have we seen that
you know queen d3 idea of being
threatened in this match
okay we have a rook trade g5 play that
does expose the black king
but already's claim is that you don't
have pieces to go and attack me with and
that knight on the c5 is really strong
yeah rookie two though good counter play
a4 by white when he gets the moment and
the moments now he says attacks that
bishop which doesn't have a lot of
places to go
so goes bishop c4 if that bishop moves
the b-2 pawn okay was hanging but that's
where the knight took
and i like all there is to control this
position knight come to e4
this looks like black has all the
activity
yeah i was even thinking maybe queen e4
uh was possible to trade queens and then
get the knight in for the same idea
well here comes c5 drops the d5 pawn
wait rookie one
pins everywhere who's pinning who here
robert
it looks like white is pinning black
because that 94 is actually under attack
the 93 is protected
and queen these what are moves of play
probably the only move to play and
what's the count two extra pawns for
white so it car
objectively doing very well here night
oh rook c1 knight f1 but
yep god i don't even know if that worked
he has ideas there what look at this
game by
ali reza i feel like he's been so tricky
right now
because he was expecting brook d7 so he
played a6 and he carved smartly but rook
d6
in anticipation of that move but look at
the clock by the way ali raza
is getting close here rook takes b6 and
work a6
yeah broke a6 okay it was rookie eight
but this probably is objectively lost
for
black but practically speaking in a time
scribble you can maybe remember do you
think he's about to
grab the a7 pawn at the right moment
yeah we i think a car is waiting for
that
he watched that match for sure yesterday
and but you can't just check now that's
a oh wait what did the car just do
he moved his rope he's gonna get flagged
here oh
my gosh he tricked him and and ollie was
trying to win on the clock he's trying
to dirty flagging but he might get
flagged he might get flagged
oh the car wins hikaru wins
what a game that was and we see just
the disbelief on hikaru's face that he
flagged ali razor from that
and on the race that leads further into
the laptop
and he is down three points today
nakamura
i wouldn't be surprised if everyone
watching at home if ali reza's head just
shows up in your living room he's about
to enter that computer screen
wow i can't believe that robert that was
insane i thought that with that dirty
move rook a1
he had it in the bank it seemed to be
the case and i'm sure that hikar felt
the same way then all of a sudden he
turns it around
and this is the exact type of system
that gave others of trouble against
glass of artemia
i said it probably more the same for me
carl he loves these types of setups
and the problem for oh well not anymore
e6 coming your way soon
you're not loving this setup that's for
sure no i liked it before when it was
closed now that it's open i hate it
but alireza said you know it's not his
type of game he wants the tactical play
and e6 doesn't quite work because the
queen will take an e6 but
uh that was barely an escape there by
icaru
100 percent uh still a great position
for ali reza he's obviously got the
bishop pair
better pawn structure bishop on g7 not
even doing anything and look at this
knight e4 yeah he gives it the bishop
pair to give black the worst pawn
structure and as you're pointing out the
bishop on g7
is kind of useless so the pawn chain
from b2 to e5 connect four
also wins in chess and this looks great
for all theresa
yeah take that pawn still though
hikaru's gonna establish a knight on d5
which is
uh tricky and really the bishop on g7
which is the issue
okay so he's just trying to go after
this white king actually
and he takes on well it was an
interesting choice to take on g7 but
alvarez
is a little bit ahead of the clock puts
his bishop the king to rookie two
and he's trying to get the e pawn going
at the right moment but hey carson
knight e3
yeah there's a 93s wow there should be
two comes though at the end
e queen bishop d2 wow
and okay i was thinking maybe rook takes
d2
play with the knight against the rook
but he decides to just go down a piece
which i don't think i agree with because
pre-moves so easy for white here you're
just throwing a check rookie five
you can just and look at this trey king
c364 just pre-move that and
oliver is it takes that one so he is
maybe a bit
faster even though he car won that time
swim before i don't know i get the
feeling that oliveriza wants that exact
scenario where they're both scrambling
with just two seconds left
because he trusts his mouth speed 100
like uh that's why honestly i was so
impressed because that is ali reza's
wheelhouse
where he had hikaru previously so
impressive by hikaru that
he was able to come back from that and
beat alireza at his own game
flagging him and look at this position
this looks great for black you control
the open a file
the e5 pawn is a target the b3 pawn's a
target knight takes b3 is a free pawn
and all the razor's playing really well
right now he sure is bishop to h3 knight
g5 i was about to say kick him right
back where he came from
can't take on f5 because the knight f3
4. look at rook a4 the knights are
protecting one another
they're not superfluous here they're
doing a great job the f5 pawn is
actually essential because that gave
black additional flexibility yeah this
is a great game by alareza but he needs
to put it away
he needs to come back in this match this
is a perfect game to start doing that
and look at bishop before tactically
defending knight and c3 if there was a
trade because 92 check ideas
and so king of fate the knights in there
for white
wow it car just walks in the pin and
doesn't mind
it feels like some kind of knight g4
knight f1 rookie m8 but how do you make
that work
yeah i mean f6f1 doesn't threatening
anything he had f6 there just kick the
knight e6
first just don't wait that drop step
somehow check i was like don't drop f7
which is why i played e6 and then i
dropped f7 with check h5
i was gonna say he wants to sink that
knight in and that is a checkmate and if
you take the night well hang on that's
another checkmate
wow so it is four to three just like
that a three game
lead is now down to one hikara probably
feeling some of the pressure here and
ali reza his
form has improved the more games that
are played yeah absolutely i feel like
he's getting used to that
laptop that he's playing on because one
thing when you start streaming robert
you actually do get used to playing on
the monitor and
with that setup every single day so he
might have always played bullet on his
laptop
goes back to it and suddenly he's just a
little you know out of sorts
well getting used to setups is important
especially in chess i mean look at this
right now alireza pushes black back he
gets rid of that bishop one g4 so he can
push his pawn there
and i mean all things consider this
looks like what
you want from the white side because you
all the space
on the king side in the center f5 is an
idea you can play g5 knight f2 knight g4
at some point trying to get your knight
into f6
so i like what alirez is doing here yeah
the knight on e4 though for black is
really nice basically if black can take
his bishop
maybe throw it on c5 i think he'd be
very happy the bishop on g7 is
not where it wants to be wow an f5
creating a weakness in e6 a french-like
idea
that could pay off but i think actually
the e6 pawn is very weak here
yeah and he's just gonna triple on the
the e file however watch that f4 pawn
after bishop takes d4
okay well that bishop sinks into the e5
square uh oh opening the f file might
not be such a good idea
white gets this outside past one but oh
bishop g5
he runs into this because he missed
queen g6 check i think that was a really
important insertion
and now it's an extra change but that
king on b7 is not safe so
even though black stop material and time
there is some hope here for ali raza
because of that
lack of king safety yeah and rookie
nicely done he keeps the queen
off the seventh and the eighth ring okay
but down goes this pawn queen e5 was the
idea of queenie for a great move by car
queen
check and e5 winning the g4 pawn now the
white king looks like it's about to get
checkmated
and look how safe that king is on a6 and
here it goes rook cheats rookie four
going to e1 with check
rookie two and he's just making steady
progress really impressive
and queen b3 there's no check for white
so he gets the mate and
one more game before the break 5'3
hikaru that was a huge game for him to
stop the bleeding he was losing a bunch
of games there now he gets a win two
game lead once more
and this game will be essential because
the two-point lead if that becomes three
heading into the break that's bad news
for alareza
yeah i mean you mentioned how important
the last game was i think this one is
critical for the match because you
mentioned it if ali reza is down
three points going into the break that
is a tough lead to overcome he's going
to need to come back the likes of which
we've seen
from you know andrew tang down five to
one and even from alabasa
yesterday to storm back when he
shouldn't even have a chance to against
artemyev
and look at these knights and look at
them clamping on the position
these pawns for white taking control of
the whole board the bishop on b7
is useless right now you would love to
play c5 but guess what there's a knight
on c5 now pawn there
that light squared bishop is no good
sometimes in positions like that
you play the move c5 as black give up an
entire pawn
just to open the diagonal because look
at the future that bishop on c8 it's not
that bright at the moment until
you know you play e5 and things change
but that was a really good decision
about alareza even though he's down a
pawn right now
he's opening that bishop you got bishop
five's coming oh that is a
bad time for a car to see e5 and look at
this the attack against the white king
and well i said until things change
things have changed things have definite
changes they're
doubling rooks on the second rank here
of rook to d2
oh he takes the a4 pawn okay that still
looks good now wait knight g6
there's a meeting net yeah nature oh no
king
h7 king agency oh my goodness
everything's mate robert brooke takes
before and then rookie eight it's made
by force yeah and ali raza
he grimaces there that is a huge victory
for hikaru nakamura who's now up six to
three
and amman we just saw out of the gates
hikaru came with some fine form took a
big lead
alireza swindled his way back a little
bit there and now the lead is ballooned
to three once more
if you're ali ray's coach what do you
tell him
happy there's a break uh really good
timing for him it was starting to
to really pull away and that's what
hikaru can do i mentioned it time and
time again when you're playing hikaru
that the game should start adding up and
you're like trying to do the math like
how do i get down
three games what where did that come
from he he does it in just a very casual
manner but
um ali reza i'm trying to remember some
of the openings that he had and i
actually did like
most of the openings that he got with
the white pieces against hikaru's setup
that sort of
c6 e6 like modern looking uh position
that he carl likes to go for
i think ali reza should keep going for
that because his positions have been
good there that
albeit the last time they had the game
he was getting outplayed by hikaru but
i feel like the openings there are
always great definitely something to go
back to
and from hikaru's perspective i was a
game seven or sorry game
eight rather instead of this last one
here at the one before when the car was
black that was a really great game by
him where he went up the exchange
converted with ease checkmated alarisa
it seems like hikaru
he stopped his problems by losing two in
a row and then he's back but
the break comes at a good time we are
going to take it we'll be back
shortly with more from this bullet chess
championship presented by sig
semi-final between akara nakamura and
ali a frusia
[Music]
all right and you see here the winner of
hikaru nakamura is a fruit match takes
on
andrew tang who's eagerly awaiting his
opponent for the final
amman hikaru has jumped out to a six to
three lead
he's doing extremely well he started off
well the middle was going on he raised
his weight then back to hikaru so
you said what must be done for all there
is going forward here it looks like he
needs to play quickly
he's getting these time deficits out of
the opening and i think that's really
coming back to haunt him game after
game yeah because what we know that uh a
strategy that uh ali reza is ready to
use and rightfully so
he's quite good at it is flagging and uh
it's it's not just
you know when there's one second left
that he's faster than hikaru i think
he believes that if he does like five
five seconds left
uh that he will be able to flag hikaru
nakamura
he's confident in his mouse speed and
he's playing on the laptop which
we made our jokes about it but honestly
laptop smaller screen that's usually
where you want to play your bullet chest
i know even when i'm streaming you got
that big monitor but sometimes uh the
you know very very strong bullet players
will actually shrink their board
so that the mouse just simply travels
less distance so i think he's setting
himself up to just be
a very speedy player but that's why it
was just so weird those first couple
games robert he was so slow
we we need to see him like get get off
to a better start as you mentioned
well let's see if we can do it here he
plays d4 once again hit cargo in the
same system game after game
just trying to take over the light
squares and play quickly and in early
h3h4 situation i think that favors white
yeah and we we usually see like this
bishop f2 eventual queen e1
and just targeting h4 and look at this
where you could take on e4 and play
knight g5
yeah this looks really good for white
the opening the f file is not supposed
to be good for black and
h4 is weak e4 can be captured i actually
can take it right now
and white's going up the pawn yeah the
the g5
pawn is loose so he locked e3 because
knight d5
oh gosh how quickly these things turn
i know look how quickly he caro finds
that move capitalizes on it
still manageable for ali reza is
actually e3 falls that can't be right
no that's the good news for el reserve
taken c3 pawn takes he can take an f5 at
any moment if he wants it
and look at this c5 he needs to get to
the b file asap like
uh he's going to rook f3 but hikar
smartly played for b6
yeah and he car's got to play c5 right
at some point get that moving
i think so and the h4 pawn is it target
wait a second rookie seven check
okay four first this looks very
dangerous for black
rook c4 move is really good he's just
gonna pick that off and if he can pick
off the h4 pawn now there's no checkmate
to worry about like the last time yeah
we just saw how that works out
and now f7 is falling once f7 falls then
e6 and g6 are very weak
this should be already's game here 100
he's got an h-bond that can run he's
winning every single pawn that he
has and the knight is just dominated by
the bishop wait there's some kind of
knight no there's no knight f1 check is
the king and slide out to g2 but you
know that
drawing mechanism that sometimes is
placed and while you're down a piece now
and
always has plenty of time to convert
this yeah i think hikaru is
probably uh playing on a little bit to
do with the the clock
not not to do with any belief that he
has a chance that no
and this is smart because hikaru has the
experience of playing in all the speed
chess championships
he knows that you should play the mascot
he's going to waste his remaining 10
seconds
and that is very smart gameplay by
hikaru nakamura
yep we've we saw ali reza's opponent
you know uh it didn't work out for him
because he wasn't looking at the match
clock that's of course artemia
so kicaro using the match clock for what
it's supposed to be used for running
down uh when you're ahead
for sure in a casual game on stream you
resign that and go to the next game
but in a match like this you have to let
the clock tick we saw what artemis if
you just mentioned that
that was disaster for vladislav so
hikaru nakamura knows better he's going
to waste the time
if it helps him wait a second is there
some kind of knight takes g2 coming
that would be very very exciting to see
a move like that with that bishop on b7
lined up
either way this looks very promising for
black because all your pieces are in
perfect squares but hikaru playing
quickly
trying to find an idea here and there it
is d4
and he goes quickly with that walking
into the pin with queen c3 and queen d2
i feel like he car was kind of flailing
with the queen but it might work out
well speaking of pins the d-file pin is
annoying and the d4 pawn is in trouble
so yep you just won the d4 pawn though
actually ali riz is out playing hikaru
maybe he's moving a little too quickly
right right b2 is hanging here as well
but he
yeah sorry f2 and rook takes g3 were a
simultaneous threat which is probably
why he played bishop d4
and that's just a much nicer way to do
it like he stops at bishop d4 you might
expect bishop b2 and pre-move in that
situation knight c6 bishop e5 where's
that rook going if you go to
okay he just trades the rooks this way
because he figures he's up two pawns
here
and optimize the board yeah i like that
decision really really smart just don't
blunder king f6 like some sort of knight
d5
but um yeah i really really like that
choice okay bishop c7 keep your pawns
protect that knight
oh i don't know about this because the h
pawn is the wrong pawn
you want to give yep give those h pawns
because that's the wrong color corner
yeah i i still think this was the right
decision it's much easier to pre-move
with black and i think he was getting
low on time so
i understand why he did that yeah for a
few moves i saw the eval bars you know
on our screen saying that oh it's
uh should be equal but not in a bullet
game and not with these split pawns like
this
and this is going to be a win for
alareza
yeah i actually don't really know why he
car didn't keep playing that position
like just go king d1 and bishop c6 and
like i don't know i think that if he's
trying to run the match clock i think he
can run it for way longer than he just
did
because i think you need to balance
running the mascot with also your nerves
and if he kept playing was losing
there's still some stress involved
oh e6 was just player like there's a
queen hanging on that f5
but you know there's some stress
involved there by the way this this
looks
absolutely terrible for black vertical
seven that's winning on the spot
wow bishop g6 and then bishop e8 and
bishop g5 yeah after the king goes to e7
bishop g5 was made so
ali rizzo storming back here 96 knight
of seven
yeah he's just storming the castle right
now queen e6 and this should be lights
out i said that these openings were
really really good for ali reza and he's
proving it here
yeah he's up how many pawns right now is
it four no
now two pawns but it looks like more and
wow c3 what a calm move just a win piece
and a car resigns and it's an
even match right now it was six three at
the break whatever ali raza fuji did let
us know
because i want to know how to storm back
into car nakamura it is a tied matchup
and talk about running down the clock
now you might want those 10 seconds that
you ran off the clock earlier back you
might need them to
to come back if ali reza wins the next
game yeah we have eight minutes
20 seconds remaining and all the reason
with the black pieces is taking a
hikaru like approach because very solid
you see the b7 c6 f7 e60 artemia of like
approach too
and just saying i have no real
weaknesses yet hikaru game after game
was up on the clock
and has been honestly punishing alireza
for these setups
it's true c5 so probably see i was going
to say the c5 pawn taken but he also
gives up the bishop i'm not sure
about that decision yeah i think you
wanted to keep the bishop here that's a
good call the f5 pawn is very strong
it's protected you see this little f7 e6
f5 configuration
now the c file is open so that should
give black some chances here
but a5 is a big problem yeah and he's
looking to gang up on this pawn bishop
d4 and brook
check is important and the brook is
trapped on b4
well we talk about resigning the same
time look already resigned
wow you had a nice tactical sequence
that one's for you
still seven half minutes remaining in
this match oh and this looks like a good
opening for white here
uh to start off that normally when you
play the queen's gamut and play
knight f6 and have to take with the
knight early on that's a nice way to get
a bad position early on in bullet
yeah it sort of looks like it's
transitioned into
a gruntfeld but probably one that white
is not unhappy about uh
okay this looks very awkward for black
but i guess the british one of six for
now is okay
bishop e2 is going to break the pin and
here if there's like bishop d4
knight takes b2 i wonder how that works
out and so he gets bishop c1 very calm
move
and this is a strange position you're
going to see this every day where the
knight
on c4 very active causing weights and
problems with the bishop on f6
is very sturdy there protected by the
pawn and the d4 squares
can be blacks for the taking well it can
be and is
at the moment uh there's no fork on c2
so
how about a fork on f5 wow i think you
can play bishop e3 because we've taken
e4 queen e4 and this bishop e6 mating
ideas
incredible yeah taking the knight bishop
queen b3's mate
or it's close to mate on the diagonal
right the bishop it's a good move we'll
put it that way
it's a damn good move wow this is very
complicated an e6 played
knight g5 yeah that looks good now just
bishop e2 just move the bishop back all
right f3
looks good too rook c1 to c7 knight
takes e6
does an a6 works oh he's lost he moved
back but a7 is hanging you could take
that
pawn and then b7 falls next right
queen h how did he see that it looked
like you're losing a piece and cuisine
forced the queen trade
and now that rook on the seventh rank
looks really good for white
ticket comes tonight here comes the
knight knight e5
wow and knight g4 back okay but hikaru
fighting off here
he really is it's all about the time
that bishop d5 coming soon
careful of the clock here yeah i think
oh that hangs a piece alaris
was moving really quickly there and rook
there's got to be some kind of mate
somewhere alireza i think did the right
thing he invested time
and now he's starting to pre-move once
he's got the keys and now it's easy you
up a piece and that means the black king
has a harder time finding squares
and it looks like hikaru just throws in
the towel doesn't want to compete with
him
in the time scribble it is seven all
still five plus minutes remaining
on the first match today it felt like
that match went by very quickly this
feels like it's going slowly still
five minutes left we've had so much
excitement yeah and i
i actually um i disagree with hikaru
there
not playing on uh i understand that you
know the superstar young ali reza is so
fast he's the favorite in the time
scramble but hey you got to put your
skills to the test you car already
showed earlier on
that he can flag alireza he you know
he's a fast player i'd like to see him
play those on
yeah i agree with you there i think
knight d4 now is kind of forced for
ferruccio's rook is in danger of getting
trapped on f5
so this trade is very strange you'll see
this very often with his pawn structure
two sets of double pawns
look at his bones you know he's crashing
through on the queen side that's his
goal
yeah and that g5 move forcing the bishop
back to d8 is quite strong here
uh you do have to watch out for the f4
pawn though and d5 coming such a strong
move
and he wants to go bishop c7 uh but we
should be six wow
i was like wait the rook's still hanging
there and he just plays like this and
takes him too far because the rook's
hanging
off that was absolutely sick that whole
sequence
that was unreal that he saw all that
he's protecting g7 so no checkmates for
white and now the pawn structure
is slightly better for black because of
this isolated f5 pawn good move by your
car the richter six
oh trade and trade everything ah i'm not
sure this works for hikaru
king f6 and you play h5 kg5
th5 okay he's pushing five and h
uh maybe h5 there was actually a really
cool move but this is queen b6 check
and they're no stalemates because of the
president a3 pawn
wow wow that game was insane honestly
masterpiece from ferrugia it
didn't look like much because they're
very small tactical subtleties but
just to be able to come out of that
position with c6 small things
rook takes g5 and then taking the end
game confidently and from
six three down to eight seven up ali
raza is on a tear right now he gets the
white piece in this game
he's going for the bishop here he could
take on g6 now he has both bishops
against two knights but the the position
is close so kind of
easy for the knights to maneuver around
and i'm not sure about this decision to
trade on d4 i think that hurts black's
king
yeah i'm not sure about that it's
important that white got to play bishop
takes d5 though the fact that black
doesn't get to anchor a knight there
really hurts his chances and maca is
just worse in this end game
yeah bishop c3 trading rooks the h3
point can't be captured his background
checkmates
so look at ali raza go he's just trading
down oh
that can go with a check yeah i didn't
love
um extra pawn i think we love it once
more
yeah i was gonna say i didn't love the
way he somehow just lost the clean pond
there
but i love the way he won a clean pun
there so and king c5 can be
six okay with these positions
in classical chess oh well not even
classically just now
rook b3 is this winning
yeah you just bring the king around e6
and i would say if it's not enough it
should be an effing bullet well look at
the clock though
his car is way ahead on time
g5 oh no he could not allow that
movement he resigns because he
understands there's just over two
minutes left and the
game lead for alareza for russia so even
if this goes the distance it car
might just have enough time to start one
more game this game is
uh well this game is for the finals
robert put it that way um
i think that hikaru is probably decently
happy with his opening
but he needs to get that free match in
really quick
yeah if i'm all there is i'm never
resigning i'm going yeah if i'm losing
this game i am playing until i have
negative time remaining because
you want that match clock to run out a
car playing very quickly here with the
white pieces i'm not even sure i like
white's
position practically speaking now i do
after that i love it yeah look at those
pawns going oh okay i changed my mind
real quick look at that pawn chain the
bishop on g2 unopposed and the long
diagonal
looking very good for a car right now
yeah and he keeps the rook on the board
rook f1
uh is there some night discovery not
really there's no good moves oh
i don't know about that letting the pawn
chain look at the light squares
oh my goodness yeah but maybe he has a
blockade
because when you have this locked up
structure like this how are you going to
break through you need a knight for
white to get to d5 or something like
that
right and he's just looking to trade
pieces go a5 stay all on the dark
squares and say hey you can't beat me
i don't buy it but um it's the right
strategy i mean it might be frustrating
to play against
and look at this your g5 is going to be
played h takes
h oh throws in g6 check but now it's
totally locked up
yeah i don't know about that you need to
maybe to play g takes h6 i think hikar
will regret that
he might still he might still win this
game but i think
that was sick oh bishop takes g7 as well
that was so sick oh my gosh we were just
talking the positions locked up but he
saw the queen joint and the taxes for
the past pawns
and speaking of past pawns there are
multiple it is a
win in a second here don't just don't
move alareza
it doesn't matter there's gonna be one
more game so you can resign it doesn't
matter it's the same thing
and we have one last game that was
exceptional by hikar enough bishop takes
h6
bishop g7 pre-moved robert because he
knew that e7 was a threat as well as g7
totally sick but now we're in the most
important game of the entire match and
must win game free kara nakamura this
decides who goes to the final
and here i think white should queen f3
good move keep the center as close as
possible because you don't want to see
that bishop hit the e4 pawn
the b4 pawn was captured and look at
that move very quickly by
car knight c5 trying to go after the e4
pawn white is up one but the bishops
look good for black
yeah and if hicara wins this we will
have that you know coveted tie break
that we've seen before
but if ali reza draws the game or wins
it that's enough to send him through
and look at this decision by others but
b5 if bishop ever took on d4
you could just trade off and then you
win the b5 but that's not going to give
you the most winning chances
for a car and right speaking of winning
chances where are they yeah ali reza
got a great position now after h4
however sometimes these solid positions
when you try to break through and go for
mate they don't work
oh there might have been a rook c5
tactic there to hit the d5 but either
way
what is black going to do here there's
some kind of queen c4 oh my gosh
just taking like king e2 yeah i think
this is a good end game for white but
bishop b4 big threat yes hikaru can't
repeat
no he can't repeat just look at this can
you two rook c7 check
throw in the checks rupee seven look at
the time though hikaru is in a position
where he can ricky three's a blunder
because rick kc seven mm-hmm
so ruby's rookie b7 how do you shoot e7
oh missionary 7 was a possibility i
don't know if it's good though and the
car is doing his best his king is around
14 seconds for all theresa so check
when's the 50 move role you'd throw in a
pawn move at some point
yeah he will play g4 i think at some
point and
there it is there it is he throws it in
he's up 10 more than 10 seconds
this is he should be four oh oh yeah but
should be four at that moment and now
and now he plays it
oh but look at that move throwing in the
check just to gain some time this is
actually
expert bull oh oh the rocks
already had the match he had the tie but
he lost his rookies
losing all of his pawns he just has to
take the pawn that's it that's the match
that's it
hikaru you can't pre-move there oh
he had that game and ali raised the
farouza for the second
day in a row he wins because of this
sneaky little
take something pre-move winning the game
and that is that alive
smiles he works his way to the finals of
the bullet chess championship and he
will face
andrew tang that wasn't even the final
he still had a whole
match i feel like that was the final and
oh my goodness i can't believe it
to ali reza's credit that was not a
dirty move he played rook c2
protected by his king he simply wanted
to trade so that wasn't that wasn't
like any of the other moves we've seen
from ali reza but
it worked out just the same hikaru
should not be pre-moving there why
he had such a time lead robert he just
needed to put his rook
safe and then pre-move the king and
leaving his rook exposed there my
goodness he gets punished for it
we will not see hikaru nakamura in the
finals and ali reza in dramatic fashion
reminds us that semifinals could be
exciting too robert
both of these matches were extremely
excited down to the wire
and ali raza was down three points
against ikaru nakamura
and yet he makes his way to the finals
ali raza i think
got in the car's head a bit some of
those time scrambles were going alirez's
way so he car said i need a pre-move
because
even though he may have five seconds
remaining that's enough time
for alireza to play and that rook was
left hanging for a couple moves there
because alvarez started pre-moving his
king away and the rook stayed
in each other's path that was a amazing
save by ali reza there he moves on to
face andrew tang
and amman before we go to break
what do you make of this finale andrew
tang
versus oliver is a frugia uh two people
that are uh
you know on top of their game right now
i can't wait to see the time scrambles
between them
because they are both capable of some of
the the most insane
moves uh pre-moves dirty moves at the
right time
calculating free moves that we've ever
seen from any player in this competition
the two most deserving players are
definitely in the final and they're both
young talented super speedy guys who
back it up with tactics and good chess
roberts so
i can't wait to get back in let's save
the hot takes for after the break
i say this often i'll say it again you
will not want to miss the action because
we have the final
of the bullet chess championship
presented by sig coming your way in just
a few
[Music]
well we are back after that exciting
finish between ali reza faruja and ikara
nakamura
and it's only fair to the players that
they get a break andrew tang has been
waiting
i'll raise the fruit he'll get a
breather so we have a compilation
from a previous bullet chest champion to
show you enjoy the video we'll be back
in a few for the finals of this year's
bcc
blue's on the clock he needs to take the
pawn to ensure the draw
yeah okay suddenly he figured it out
he's only got three seconds but he
should still be able to win
that connection just went from you know
one bar to four bars so at the very
least sergey has a chance
he's got stalemate don't worry he's got
a queen oh my king h2
king nobody's gonna lose on time
oh my god that's hilarious you saved the
game
oh my gosh to a knight lavon
doesn't even act like he doesn't even
act like it was like
uh nothing but a thing he just under
promotes to a knight with check
and saves the game that was so great
oh my gosh
[Music]
i have a question to maxim okay have you
have you considered
plastic operation
on which part of my body
if you were talking about shaving so i
thought you know
you might as well just uh
[Laughter]
you know justice nothing
interesting nobody knows where we're
going with that
and put it back where it belongs
okay i don't know who's better here and
why i don't know who's better either
robert
i'm freaking out i think it's a draw i
think with best place to draw because
probably best play is a draw king d5 the
knight was almost trapped so you
actually the
yeah he should have played king d5 not
sure why hikaro went for this he's going
to settle on the draw
unless he's got a win with h3 you're
gonna keep on he's gone
oh my god oh my oh my god what a swindle
oh that was so i almost cursed on
chess.comtv for the first time in my
life
honestly it might have been winning at
that point because the bishop cut the
king off and if the king could run to h2
like that
it might have been maybe he's winning
the whole time did takara have the
foresight to see that idea
i don't know oh my gosh very very nice
technique here you could even
consider giving up the bishop for that
pawn and it was probably winning yeah
but this is uh
gonna be pretty straightforward in fact
you have the bishop of the right color
corner so it should just be
easy money as they say oh my god
oh my god i saw that coming i was gonna
make a comment about the king on h8
you had no more moves you oh my god
that was the best thing that's happened
all day
is now up a game and uh again remember
everybody at six games
wins a set those asking in the chat well
then how long does the match go well one
of the most exciting things about
high-level chenis genus oh janice
fortieth slip it's a genus match
our next concept open king got him down
on time and bullet and i think levon's
gonna convert uh
she's the lady on d1 so he has to give
back the knight
take that pawn and they're quitting
anything
it's real quick oh my gosh bishop d5
and he's got made him one oh i lose this
on the clock
oh my gosh because the queen somebody
give me something to chew on
i want to bite something but look at
that 93 it's also threading made on f1
he misses it
and he's going to the quarterfinals
semifinals oh my god maxine phrases his
hands
maxine my gosh what an
epic match oh holy crap
pawns up blunders the mate on f1
and it was the checkmate previously
set up by the four key moat heard around
the world queenie ii was the only move
to guard the mate
okay he would have gone down the
exchange but still chances he plays
queen d2 and the reason it was over
everybody is rook f1 the only option was
to trade
maxine would have delivered the goods
but the eagle has landed
and we now know who are all of our
semi-finals uh competitors will be
queen e6 just play queen e6 oh
you know queen d8 prevents the rich
dicks of seven wow what a pin
what a nice fine yeah carl renews it
he puts the queen on c5 look for brook
takes f7 followed by bishop takes d5
discover discoverating discoveries we
just discovered some discoveries omen
omg's are snaps
oh man bishop takes d5
checks still good maybe but he's also
got a whole lot of time
on the clock here and whoa
it's sick lord nick shakes his head how
could you find that with only
a few seconds that's unbelievable i
don't know
but he does it all the time it's so
frustrating
like what are you supposed to do he's
not doing this quickly enough
no he's not no he's not he's only got
seven more moves can he do it oh oh it's
fake
he did it he missed it
he got it he did it
oh my god what a legend oh my god how
did he pull that off
offering you some lessons do you want to
take some bullet lessons from me
well that's a very generous offer
considering the fact that maybe bullet
is the only thing
you're gonna teach me and not just in
chess
that's right that's right but what do
you what do you think you want to play
some more bullet i mean like we can we
can do this more often
the thing is i believe that
bullet is fun but there are so many
other fun things
right that can last longer than one
minute so
are you sure about that
[Laughter]
and yes i play very little you know my
choice
[Laughter]
danny you're still live over there sorry
you got me with that one
[Music]
and as we get set for the finals we want
to give a huge shout out to the partner
sig if you want to use your gaming
skills in your career
susquehanna international group is a
leading global proprietary trading firm
that uses game theory and decision
science to win in the financial markets
to learn more about sig visit sig.com
slash chess and as you can see on screen
now
alireza ferruga is back he was taking a
break he is streaming
his performance he's become more and
more of a streamer lately in addition to
his top level play
amman it's great to see him on camera
and what do you think does he look a
little bit nervous
uh i think that the if you had nerves
coming into today
you probably reserve them for the last
match especially i don't know if you
warmed up with any bullet games
because uh oftentimes your first bullet
games of the day
are kind of your shakiest that's what
happens with a lot of players so
i think if he did have nervous robert
he's probably quelled them by now
feeling pretty good about himself and
using that momentum going into his match
with andrew
and he did just defeat hikarnak more 10
to 8 and he moved on to face andrew tank
who's had
quite a breather he's been waiting for
this finals matchup and
we have andrew on screen with alireza as
we're set up here
andrew he's i wonder if this hurt him
because
after beating donya in that very close
match he's probably feeling good
and in bullet you want to be in the flow
you want to keep going
and having to wait for a while like this
maybe he's out of his rhythm
i agree i think that is a a very valid
point and
it would probably throw me off i think
i'd rather be farouza in this situation
because you just had your match so i
think that you're more in the rhythm and
of course it'd rather be for roger
because he's wearing some chess bra
merch as well robert looks like that
plus 200
uh elo i was talking about might have
paid off last match oh that c9 gear
doesn't look too bad either so andrew
tang repping
his esports orc and we're off i see the
first game is just starting here
and andrew gets the white pieces these
are two of the highest rated bullet
players
on the site actually ferrugia has taken
the number one spot
but how do you like the start of the the
game here where black is castle white's
king goes the other way
well i'm familiar with this line as
pretty dangerous for black actually this
long
castle idea and you know you can see
what's gonna happen moves like f4 bishop
d3 knight f5
and just throw everything you've got at
the king side
it could be more dangerous than you
think that's true and
well andrew up a few seconds here now
over five so that's looking good for him
some kind of bishop c3 knight e4 b5 look
at all the reason play on the
queen side over here i don't see the
attack against the king that's why he
plays g4
and i guess g5 is maybe just oh if
there's rooks you want maybe it's a
little slow though it could be
g5 and knight h6 almost looks like
that's the idea behind rook g1
he takes an f5 and he just brings his
knight right back so that way
his knight wasn't blocking the bishop
that was on state now the opening of the
queen side
oh gosh i'm worried about andrew's king
i don't see the checkmate ideas for
white
especially now that bishop d3 is out of
the cards yeah he's hitting the rook on
g3 well we see rook h3
and what g6 is defending against that
idea for the moment
this is a very hectic game and andrew is
up 10 seconds
doing very well on the clock trying to
attack versus king but we just saw what
version can do
even when he's down 10 seconds yeah and
like v3 is coming in
that bishop's very valuable on d2 as
well if you want to even take that
oh yeah this looks like it's much
clearer how black proceeds
you can put a rook on b8 that's what he
does you could take on d2 take on c3 and
knight a4
just keep going with the attack he
trades queens first because the attack
for black still exists
exactly that you don't need the queens
on the board for this attack oh man
there's
there's some stuff happening here wait a
second all these pieces were just
captured and that king rookie hadn't
checked
it was 97 overlooked but nine seconds to
seven seconds
i think that andrew has a much better
position and good chances
because of the king safety oh or not oh
that that's two pieces though that just
disappeared
oh my goodness and look at that all the
races even on the clock and he steals
all the pieces
how do you just do that so good the guy
is a magician
yeah that this is very easy conversion
even blundering that that rook doesn't
matter too much
and andrew shakes his head he shows some
emotion there usually he's pretty stoic
that times i can't believe what i just
did i was completely winning and ahead
in the clock
and this is a wild start to a great
finals
yeah and we saw like look forward to
more of those time scrambles robert
because
we're gonna see them go exactly like
that one guy is going to completely
embarrass the other one and just look
like a total magician
and it's not going to be the same guy
every time it's a dangerous start for
andrew of course he lost the game so
that's a bad start but i think because
fruit is the stronger player in terms of
classical chess
andrew needs to make the most of those
scrambles
yep that's a good point here rook c5 i
mean i feel like white's full commit
on the queen side starting to worry
about the other side of the board
yeah you can't just go all in on the c5
when the king says being opened up here
and i like the way andrew's playing this
really great bishop f8
traps the work on c5 and he just
overlooked basically that
that sneaky move rook d8 was actually
guarding the d-pawn to enable bishop to
f8
yeah rook d didn't even look like he did
anything but you're right
it helped trap the rook there with queen
c2 rook g5
wait this doesn't look very safe for the
black king h3 is hanging but then maybe
queen e2 comes in threatening
and this is worse queen of five because
the queen's aiming to h7 rook takes h5
is coming
and i don't think you can stop it you're
losing your queen no you can't do
anything here the best you can do is
sack your queen for something but
you might even give up the game because
this looks brutal
and now white has a queen and a knight
and some pawns for the two rooks oh oh
this looks like a mating attack
take with the pawn f6 yeah 95 also jumps
in as well
queen h8 and win the rook on c8 and a
resignation two nothing for frugia
wow that was a very impressive game
because it started to look like it was
flipping
after bishop f8 but then the comeback
and just the the exposed black king
right and it is two nothing in for
rouge's favor we will fix the score on
screen everybody don't worry
and now we have the same opening as
the first game which worked out well at
first it seemed like for alareza then
the tables turned and it was good for
andrew but i like this opening for black
yeah i
i initially liked it for white but it
seems that this b5 followed by
c4 idea that's become really critical
and
tang is having a tough time dealing with
it yeah it just
has some banko gambit feels and then the
king is on the queen side which is not
what you want in a bank of gambit
because
the position is being ripped open yeah
knight e4
speaking of being ripped open bishop c3
next and some knight f6 ideas are
looming
and i wonder what other reasons think
about bishop d4 maybe to defend the f6
score he goes knight a4
yeah c4 is super hanging here bishop
takes g4 and knight f6 check just
winning material probably winning a lot
of material
now that you mention it yeah and the c4
was tempting
but the other way was probably better
look at this king on c1
oh rook c4 and rook c8 wow you get that
queen
what a tactic and it's not going to be
like totally over but
obviously this is pretty convincing yes
although this knight f6 check idea is
still
available for white so plus queen g7
threatening queen takes d4
jeez he doesn't want to take the queen
yet
so queen a1 yep queen a1 looks good
okay knight c3 wow rook a4 and the
knight in g4 is lost
in this b2 check at the end
what a situation here all right just
making this tricky andy spent too much
time he's got 70 seconds
and where's that king going and queen f2
check is now a threat
nice move 92. it it doesn't matter i
think at some point alarez stopped
calculating because
his move queen threatening on b2 was
enough to win this game
and andrew's shaking his head he is not
enjoying this final here
alireza he's spending time early but
then he's finding all these strong moves
that forces andrew to start spending
time in return and alaris is now up 3-0
this is an amazing start if you're an
ali raza fan right now
however if you're andrew tang there have
been some time scrambles which were so
close i think back to game one
that game should have been you know one
that was you know his for the taking
but he started to hang all his pieces
that's one thing is that i think tang is
just as fast
but ali reza seems to have these
pre-moves at the end of the game
where he also finds a lot of accuracy
whereas tang is hanging a lot of pieces
that's right and tank is a slow starter
he was down five to one against nihal
sauron in the quarters
in the semis he was down by two games
and diana nardiski and then he
wins when it counts and he has made his
way to the finals here so let's
still keep of course an eye on his play
see if he's able to
right the ship here but it's not a good
start this position also is bad for
black
white controls the c file the pawn c7
second plays f4 f5 as a threat
oh this is a problem yeah so he gives up
the c pawn because
honestly that was the lesser of two
evils you can't let f5 happen you'll get
you know blown apart on the king side
which is the same way he lost the last
game like this
and look at that move rook a1 trying to
pin the rook so the queen on d3 was
going to be lost and that's why rooksy
won't drop back in
i like the way andrew's playing right
now in comes the knight to f5
and oh there has to be some kind of
follow-up so he's trying to overtake c4
i like this bishop
h4 maybe bishop h4 to try to trade and
get on the second rank here
d5 d6 that's now you're if you're moving
backwards like this this is a problem
for black
and the time no way no way this is good
knight d5 next
yeah this is just oh the rook hangs
unfortunately for andrew
alireza i think he has the most
confidence that they're beating a car in
that match
yeah i mean he's he's currently blanking
a
3300 player like andrew tang and
for that to even be a sentence you know
i'm talking about one of the best
players on the site
and i think we're seeing just like we
saw against
nihal sarin tang gets into these opening
systems and then he doesn't change even
when it's not going his way
this is the third time we're seeing this
opening and the first game he actually
obtained a winning position eventually
though he was in trouble earlier
the second time it looked like alireza
played a pretty smooth game and here we
have the position once more i like black
yeah they've they're working out for ali
reza and uh
one thing that he did use the the time
for very effectively was the break
the half time he used very effectively
in his previous match
to actually change the openings but he's
losing so many games from the same
opening that
that's probably not going to be enough
yeah this
situation where the black king is
actually very safe here and the white
king looks open now
d4 is hanging rookie eight e4 is hanging
i mean the the moves are
seemingly very simple for black and
white's position just feels very
difficult to work with wow what an idea
of rookie check king h7
the queen's under attack the knight on
d4 is under attack there's probably
checkmating threats
i mean what a performance by alireza
this is this is probably over here
this is probably over yeah and i think a
big question that
people are having right now is will ali
reza break 3 400
will he end the match at 3 400. true
oh oh my gosh bishop c 2 doesn't quite
work doesn't quite work
good defense by tang he's also down 15
seconds though yeah
it's the 15 seconds that's gonna be
killer here because look at black's king
it's not a threat in the world well if
the queen can get to the last rank
then there would be a rookie chain made
but that's hard to accomplish
okay queen step one one step one the
quincy one i like b2
probably just is good enough and now
queen d2
queen c1 he doesn't need to overreact
here and i think he is
uh fuji needs to make a move oh oh wow
okay
that's some lag there i think he
delivered a check i was like i was like
there's
no way you spend that much time in that
position no no no
no no he he didn't he was wise to spend
some time to
be precise but he was able to take that
one home
that makes sense five nothing because
when you have a lead like that robert
like that much time
you you can just lack accuracy and it's
not a big deal
you know you can blunder things here and
there you don't have to play perfectly
and you know you are going to flag your
opponent yeah as long as you don't
blunder a checkmate you're winning that
game exactly and so
right here white is castle semi open f
file
tend to like these positions for white
look at the knight on a5 it's off to the
side
not getting back into the game anytime
soon oh okay maybe
i suppose you're doing your thing again
robert i'm doing i talk about a piece
that's not good it immediately improves
so rook a7 is possible he goes here that
way he can go 94 once the knight moves
yeah is there an h5 move maybe yeah i i
don't know about this because knight e4
just
really looks troublesome that's why rook
d1 was played to protect
d4 and f6 oh gosh you couldn't take on
e4 because queen shot was mate now you
take on g7 and just open up that king
he's trying to say after g6h5 that
you're regretting that but i'm not so
sure
yeah rookie six comes there's richie's
six ideas look at him just doubling on
the e file
rook takes e4 for 96. his rook takes e8
okay but those kind of tactics
are in the air yep definitely especially
after a move like king h7 or something
like that
yep and if queen g5 the knight hangs and
there's no mate because the queen's on
f8 wait this is actually
what what was the tank tank turn this
around
take care i don't even know what the
move was there i think it was queen
h3 because the knight on d7 was wow
but to see queen h3 was a ridiculous
looking move
now tang is up a rook and a knight and
he's back everybody he's back
rookie one's mate okay so stop queen d4
okay
well that's not going to do that and
that will be uh a win
10 getting on the board now we have seen
uh
you know a comeback from you know five
to one
this one's 5-0 now it's five one i think
this one counts
i've seen tang do this before and he i
think he won the game at the right time
to make a comeback
what did we just see was there's a g
pawn missing
for both sides but for white is down a
ponzo there was some early g4 here
d4 knight f6 g4 a common bullet opening
actually so you just play e4 right after
and take the center
known as the gibbons wyden hogan gambit
accepted i have never heard of this i
think i was better off not knowing about
it but black's position here
you're up a pawn but your king is still
in the center of your castle queens and
your king will not be safe over there
either
so i actually kind of like this from a
practical point of view
yeah no especially in bullet it's uh
very
very tough to handle knight f4 maybe
stack sack on g6 or e6
and knight b5 at some moment okay castle
queens now is the right time
so he doesn't go for the d6 pawn instead
just develops the bishop
and still looks very complicated it does
c3 looks like a fantastic move though
cutting the diagonal and taking control
of d4 and 265
oh wait he could have gotten that pawn
back yeah i feel like he just didn't
want to trade
probably not trading but now he's
trading and he's not winning a c5 pawn
for it
stand if you do dan if you don't and
f takes e 95 then take on c5 so
something weird is happening all across
the board i can't quite
he's not taking that c pawn robert he
doesn't want it yeah and i'm
not sure why because that's an important
pawn to take and
oh queen a4 and the knight e3 is c4
that's you should've taken the c pawn
yeah it comes back to bite you oh the c
pawn is winning for rouge of the game
here just queen c6 trade queens and
you're up in exchange and
have some past bonds although the time
situation
but all the race is too fast he's too
fast um
i would be very surprised if this didn't
work out we all know how fast tang is
but
when you're when you're up material
usually you have an easier time
converting well there goes some of the
pawns
unfortunately there's that one pawn
that's left f2 is played
so you could take the pawn but you're
down a full rook you are knights are
tricky
but i think frozen did a good job
handling them there yeah i agree
and now he's at brooke and fridge also
has a knight and why did he pre-move c5
it's always really good to pre-move
checks because then if your opponent
does a dirty move you can catch it
wait what was that what was that we're
heading towards close
it's close okay i think tang might lose
on time
oh my gosh king d5 you got that one look
how fast alireza is it's insane
wow and alvarez was up a rook and he
gave it away which
was a risky choice but it helped him win
on time so alireza first
up six to one and i know tang has come
back from
some big deficits this one is looking uh
it's getting to be a bit too large
yeah this would not only be the biggest
deficit but in
you know the stakes that are around this
match as well this being the final
it would be the the most impressive you
know comeback i think i've seen in a
long long time this is the last
before the break oh and otherwise you
drops his queen he was expecting queen
takes d7
i took with the knight so he wins the
queen but other razer is going to
run the clock out he he knows the last
game before the break he's just gonna
waste time
because he's going to be up four points
after this game yeah
i mean well the thing is i never
understand people sitting there and
wasting time if you're gonna waste time
why aren't you
moving i just don't understand that i
think it's emotional
from a logical point of view you're
absolutely right if you're gonna waste
time just keep playing that way your
opponent has to spend time
rather than just losing the clock but as
we see alareza taking a drink from his
water here
he's just trying to get this memory just
remove it from his mind
and you just say drink some water get
ready for next game
but yeah it must be emotional because it
makes so much sense if you
that's your strategy and it's very
reasonable one uh makes a move so your
opponent's gonna use 20 30 seconds as
well
yeah you're absolutely right because
tang got to save a bunch of time
and he now goes into the halftime break
down
four points so that's a good news for
tang the bad news is
you're still down six to two so amman i
think we both agree that
tang needs to switch that opening that
he keeps playing with white
yeah that's that's like the first thing
and he has to his credit done a good job
of utilizing the break
for things like that i feel like during
the match he doesn't address very well
he's a system player he likes he likes
what he plays and he keeps playing it
but when it's not working i feel like in
a match
when he's playing and just clicking
rematch it's tough to adjust for him
some players are better at that but when
he gets time to step back from the match
and use the break
take those five minutes i feel like he's
really good so that change might
actually
really help him in the second half but
if he starts the second half
losing one even two games at that point
robert you're getting in the territory
where
mathematically might not even be
possible for him to come back
you're absolutely correct he seems to be
a second half player so we're going to
take a break and we'll return to the
second half of this bullet chess
championship final presented by sig
i got into playing poker in college and
really liked it but
never considered i could make a career
out of it until jeffy ass came and gave
a talk at harvard
jeff explained that yes you can actually
use gaming skills for your career and
for something to do on a day-to-day
basis
which was exciting at the time i thought
it was really cool we can pretty much
guarantee you that we'll give you the
best education you will be taught
all that we know in a very professional
manner by expert teachers
and you're going to be mentored and i
like to think that there's no other
place where you can get as much
mentorship as you can than susquehanna
i think that the main thing that
everybody has in common is a
sense of competitiveness and interest in
in gaming and
strategy in general i would say you're
you're playing a game as a career
it's very satisfying to me that we've
been able to employ so many people
give them not just an opportunity to
make a lot of money but to be with the
smartest people in the world
and to have a lot of fun and make a lot
of friends and create a culture
of reason
[Music]
you see how they arrived in the finals
it is alireza ferrugia vs andrew tank
farouza
knocked off artemiev then nakamura tang
defeated nihal sarin and daniel
nareditsky just to make their way here
i'm on it's been a lot of fun thus far
6-2
in alireza's farouza favor but he cannot
take his foot off the pedal here he
needs to keep it up he lost that last
game by just
hanging his queen in the center of the
board yeah i think he should be the
heavy heavy favorite obviously
but what can go wrong for him what are
the possibilities for tank
well uh number one is overconfidence and
i think that also plays into the fact
that uh the players are underway
also plays into the fact that tang you
mentioned is the second half player
he always has a better second half than
a first half it seems no matter what
and if farouza starts to get a little
overconfident like yeah this match is in
the bag
i can i can drop a few games here and
there any type of that mentality and
it gets out of hand what is this i mean
we we said not to play the same opening
and he just had to block
a pin of his queen with his rook and the
bishop doesn't even need to take the
rook on d3
that's how good ferrous position is yeah
so
i think uh i think ali reza is going to
be okay this game i mean
at least that's my initial feeling
because how do you play the same opening
and then get a worse position than any
time you've played it before
yeah i wonder if you know looking at
tank's face if he's kind of just
like resigns the fact that he's in
trouble here but this is
the worst possible position he could get
out of the break
where he plays the same opening and he's
down in exchange with
no compensation it's true that's
perfectly summed up there and uh i feel
like he might be
just going on a little bit of bullet
tilt at this point
yeah and one of the problems is you know
that there's a time limit if you're
playing
against somebody like donya or against
ferugia but you're just playing on
stream and
you play until you feel like stopping
then you can get back in the swing of
things here you know that there's
only a finite amount of time and right
well it's not looking good for a tank
no it's not as we we see rook f5 like
some some energetic moves from tank
coming out developing with tempo
but it's just not enough i mean the
knights are going to coordinate knight
g5
everything's protected here look how
solid black's position is and
white's only chance to use those light
squares okay the nikon f4 but the
problem is you don't have
safe pawns the d5 pawn will be lost as
soon as the knight moves
so there's just not a really easy okay
taking don't have time either that's the
problem
oh i thought queen h7 there's knight on
g5 yeah i also thought the same thing
so queen back i'll play 96 at some point
i think
yeah okay there's the queen trade and
that should be gg with four seconds left
this would be too impressive uh if we
see the
hey king brook takes b2 giving up the
rook for the check
that cost andrew some serious time and
well yeah he's just up too much time
plain and simple if rick p2 is even a
move for just considering
let alone playing then he's got way too
much of a time edge and
the reason he had that time edge was
wasn't because of his speed necessarily
but it was because of his moves early on
he was like pinning the queen nearly
winning it out of the opening that
caused andrew to slow down and drop
10-15 seconds early on
yes and now well it looks like andrew
drops a pawn in the center of the board
plays f5 he's playing energetically he
used that word in the previous game
unfortunately he's down material so he
could play with all the energy he wants
if he's dropping pieces
that might not help his cause it's true
it's not going to cover it now
something like bishop g4 and like
sacking on f3 big idea here
but nice move e5 to shut that bishop off
from the h2 square
oh you're blocking d5 with the rook
which somehow survives because they
don't testify
but barely barely is a great word for
this position because bishop c5 guarded
by the rook which is guarded by the pawn
and look at what are these rooks in this
position doing
i'm going to say black's rook looks
better than white's rook does but the
rook on g3 now looks useful so
okay good tactical vision by tang the f3
square you could take
double in white's pawns there but he
wants to keep the bishop he wants to
keep the threats alive the f2 square in
particular
wait can you take on f3 well he can take
now i'm wondering how
that end game is he doesn't go for but
he could have won a pawn
definitely seems like that there's no
way they repeat here well now e7 just
wins the rook on f4
wow that's that should be game
yes he doesn't even take the rook he
goes queen e5 because there's no way to
stop checkmate
queen e5 is a ridiculous move just e it
equals queen you can't even take because
queen g7 is made no robert queen e5 is
is
actually an insane move there's queen
takes f4 in the position there's e takes
f8
there's queening but he goes queen e5
takes nothing
yeah which means that maybe the only
better move there was queen c3
you do the same thing but on a less
active square but either way that was
really impressive game there by ferrous
he's now up eight to two
with just under ten minutes remaining
there still is a mathematical
possibility if tang goes on a six-game
winning streak
good luck doing that against el razor
frusia yeah and if you want to talk
about winning streaks it has to start
right now um his position does look like
uh
like one that he could press especially
after knight d4 but we have to start
talking about
winning every single game from here on
out okay but this looks like a win
for white right now queen f3 check take
on e4
uh where's the 95 check e5 yeah that
queen's not defended
oh you have to see knight c5 andrew
oh he takes it still there it's still
there it's still available
but this still should be winning the
queen can't go to c6 with knight a5
now knight c5 again and this time he's
protected it's protected
you andrew andrew no
that's just it's just not his match it's
that's the best way to put it i mean
that's that's the type of thing
uh you know andrew sees blindfolded you
know with 15 seconds
and he's still looking pretty good over
here looking good
queen takes f7 now you pass deep on you
have a bunch of pawns
d7 uh this is really getting pushed upon
he might regret that but he's still
taking everything
he's still doing well but you can just
tell that something's a little off in
this match for him
yep like rookie bishop e5 there's a
threat all of a sudden
threats can be annoying and i wonder
also about the stylistic matchup because
like tang farouz is a very tactical
player right but it seems like ferg's
openings are more solid because tank
keeps going for these openings that
honestly have been dropping in material
and okay six seconds left you have to
move
you are probably winning this game quite
oh nice
he tried it uh b5 checkmate so he takes
that wow well done by version not to get
mated
but an extra piece forex8 made
oh didn't see checkmate one and that
would be stalemate except for the h pawn
oh
man so listen i'm happy that that andrew
got that game because
uh he deserved one here there and that
was a good game but
uh man if anything i'm just happy that
this might be closer match if he makes
if he starts to come back right now
because uh that tactic missed on c5
was it was too much it was too much you
don't expect that from tangent
he does get the w unfortunately for him
down five points still
seven and a half minutes he does have a
mathematical chance
it's just super unlikely and he needs to
keep winning
no choice yeah and if you're ali reza
with a lead like this i think you can
already start to be just hyper conscious
of the match clock
that is a very viable strategy anything
it might just work
if you take every game to more or less
the limit and while
the structure have to open up i get the
feeling that
this is going to be good for white
knight d d5 looks good yeah
bishop on b3 looks excellent as well and
he plays rook to c
would that work to c1 if i was going to
move record in the e rook to c1 first
he ends up getting away with it because
the rook couldn't go to see it in 97
check
that's right king h7 so i mean obviously
two bishops here for black but these are
not the type of two bishops that you
talk about in the books
no and all right good effort thus far if
you trade rooks does quincy one check
things like that so white needs to be
careful and actually the lead on the
clock is pretty substantial
for tank it is it is tanks going back to
what he is very good at which is
starting to build up that lead earlier a
lot of players i think are a bit faster
than him more accurate at the end of the
game
tang he builds it up earlier he's very
sneaky with it and he stole the e4 pawn
bishop coming to b7 that king on g2 not
very happy
no bishop ooh the g4 is hanging as well
queen eights mate oh my goodness that
pawn on b5 is actually perfectly placed
it's incredible and tang is just he
can't
probably can't believe it like that's
just the worst it's just the worst
feeling it's force me
the game was going his way like he was
actually
taking down i'll rise in that one he
outplayed him and then
as soon as he gets a better position
loses sight of his king safety and
that's made
wow he's back to this line and
at this point it's it's i think it's
mathematically out of hand
um if farouja wants it to be and based
on what we saw in the artemia match
farouz is a guy who's very aware of the
match clock
yeah he keeps a close eye on that i
don't think he'll be
giving this match away or giving any
extra games he'll play it down to the
wire we saw him
actually in the final game before the
break he lost on time because he knew
that he should start
uh getting rid of the remaining clock so
five minutes
15 seconds remaining black's position
looks good here as well
white's king is not very safe so for all
this pieces jumping forward against the
black king it's
always the white king that's in danger
yeah i don't know how that
happened because uh the the opening is
supposed to be like hey white's
attacking but ali reza has
made a point of being the one there
first every game
yeah this is just not tang's day the
openings
not working out for him and well i think
all credit to ali reza faruja because he
defeated hikaru nakamura in a very
stressful match a very nerve-wracking
match
and yet he comes right back after a
brief
recess and then he just shows his might
against andrew tank
yeah super impressive because that is uh
not easy to do the road to the finals
for both of these guys has been
very very intense and obviously beating
hikaru
probably gave ali reza the confidence
that he needed coming into this one
what a performance by the youngster and
queen d3 check just for good measure
check here's a taking c4 check
that is extreme precision you didn't
have to but he did that's allie reza for
and he wins the queen
i mean the guy is just on another level
yeah well welcome to the ali reza show i
mean
um this is this is not really uh i would
say a firm indication
of of ferugia over tang but in this
match it absolutely is
yeah we we're just talking about that
when donya and andrew played they played
each other so many times donya came into
the match with the lead in their
head-to-head record
and tang defeated him and now alaresa is
going to take home this title it looks
like
and what a performance for tang you got
to feel for the guy
he must be pretty hyped after beating
danya he's still going to leave with a
nice payday but he wanted that title
he did and i think everyone in this
tournament could say the same thing
obviously
everyone's a competitor here and we're
playing for cash money so
obviously everything's on the line and
there's no money split by win percentage
so you'll just get the second place
prize if you're andrew tang
three minutes and change remaining ten
to three score
and i'm looking at the ratings right now
86 for ali reza perugia
incredible like it is possible that he
gets very close to 3 400 if he keeps his
win streak up
and look at his pawns it may spawn just
keep going
yeah hang on those can't be stopped
there's knight d5 track as well
okay so you can't move the bishop
because rook h1 is made so do not take
on d3
just don't play that move forward that's
why you played g4 i think we might i was
going to say i think we might see h5
h4 but instead obviously he takes the
pawn plays g5 and he's covering
everything
and he's starting bishop f5 check and so
the king is going to dark squares
because
the rook just staring at each other
through the bishop crazy and he dropped
the eep on as well
everything is falling apart here oh
bishop five oh my
oh he missed it he had it for that one
turn
wow i think tang might get this game as
a result of that oh the king walked into
light square now these knights are just
they're everywhere okay there's a
discovery whoa
um the night wait the rook can be one's
hanging
those nights what the heck is going on
oh
oh my gosh now the two knights are still
there but
white is up on exchange and on the clock
oh rook c5 nice move nice find there
and that's what you do you play rook a2
you get that rook so
far away from the knight you don't want
it anywhere near because uh you're king
because it gets porked
that's right so that's why the rook is
on the queen side
oh my gosh he flagged him he didn't need
to play that rook move
just any rook move would have done for a
flag but that move caught
andrew off guard and another win for ali
reza
who there's no way he gets eight points
for this win is there
no i don't think so i can't believe that
that was
exceptional he i think he was worried
that he was going to lose on time
so that's why he took on g4 to make sure
that he could not lose the game even if
his time runs out
and he flagged tang in the process who
was not expecting the sacrifice
and once again we see this opening but
that now the bishop on g4 is in trouble
it is and there's just the pawns are
gonna okay this is maybe the best one
we've seen from andrew so far
i agree rookie the best for last look at
that move
just to take control center queen of
five is knight f6 check so oh
uh knight of six well
tang's gonna see that one and it looks
like well i was gonna say he's gonna go
out on a win
but i think they're gonna have one
working it's funny because
under other circumstances you just let
the clock run out make a couple moves
then the match is over
but when you're up by seven points yeah
let's get one more why not it's fun
yeah yeah at this point uh both players
know the uh
overall result of this match they know
that farouza is obviously
gonna win this match but hey it's bullet
chess and these guys just love to play
and i see some people talking about this
and it is
somewhat true when you say that already
shouldn't even have been here because
against artemyev vladislav could have
let the clock run out and sometimes
you see this in sports where the team or
the person that just
barely survives and you know
quote-unquote shouldn't be there
they're the ones that go on to keep
winning because hey now they're playing
with house money there's
no oh man there was like queen h7 check
there bishop h7
and the bishop hanging on b4 there was
some nasty stuff available
that would have been that would have
been a nice way to go up for ali reza
but he's looking for a brilliancy here
he just resigns because he says yeah he
says okay i'm out of here
yeah i'm down to peace i don't see a
checkmate for me yeah whatever i won the
match
so this is the champion of the 2021
bullet chess championship presented by
sng
it is ali raza farouja i know there are
many foruga fans out there he is
streaming live right now
you can go to india stream after this of
course we are actually going to
bring him on for an interview so you
will not want to miss that
and amman what can we say about that
dazzling performance
uh first of all take uh take nothing
away from from tang he had an amazing
showing in the bull chest champion he
made it to the final he's walking away
padding his pockets with a nice second
place prize of six thousand dollars
and uh he he obviously gave us tons of
entertainment
that being said don't forget about ali
reza because
everything in this tournament he earned
he
survived against artemyev that was
probably the biggest scare
that's nothing on him that's artemia if
not playing the match clock the way
you should as a competitor and he's
going to take that opportunity
you mentioned it he's gonna he's gonna
make it count like if
if you get a chance in life you gotta
make the most of it and i would say
coming back beating hikaru with a
comeback victory and then
crushing andrew tang in the finals i'd
say that's making the most of it
he definitely flexed he made it count
all the way up to 10k that's his prize
for an exceptional bullet run we are
going to take a quick break when we
return
we will be back with the bullet chest
champion ali raza farouja
[Music]
and we are joined robert and myself
joined by grand master ali reza farouja
and the last time we heard from you
alireza this was a couple matches ago
now you're obviously the bullet chess
champion let me start with this
how does it feel yeah it really feels
great because i played two years
in final and i'm lost so i'm happy at
least together
to win to get the win this time yeah
absolutely alerts congratulations and i
think the first question that really
need to be asked
what went into your wardrobe decision
today how did you choose that shirt
oh i think it's very comfortable so i i
i didn't have more comfortable shirt
than this so
that's a that's an amazing question and
an even better
answer couldn't be better
[Laughter]
well all jokes aside uh going back to
your
match with hikaru uh you know that felt
as intense as a finals match to robert
and i while we were commentating
though you obviously were down a lot of
games in that match i think it's
something yeah
six to three so how did you turn it
around and make a comeback
yeah after after during the break i was
down six to three so yeah i had to
change
uh some of my openings and
some some i thought i have to play more
relaxed and
playing more like i'm playing uh
like every day against naruto or
like this so that way i thought i could
have a chance at least so
yeah i mean have a chance and you
stormed back there
and going into the final game you had a
one point lead
you seem to be very aware of the match
clock at all times how are you feeling
going into that game and then when you
had about five seconds left
and he hung his rook what was going
through your mind right yeah
it was very strange by the curve because
he had a thing around 15 seconds right
so i i didn't understand why
because he also hung it for two moves
right yeah
so yeah it was pretty strange it was a
little bit luck of course but in overall
i think i played good chess against
ikoro and
um the first games were a bit shaky but
after that i think it was pretty decent
yeah
yeah and i mean it looks like to us that
your good chest against hikaru
translated into the final do you think
that the fact that you had the second
semi-final match do you think that
matters at all
whereas andrew has a long break before
he plays you again
um i'm not sure because i was really
like still
still in the shock of winning against
the car so
um it was also disadvantage for me but
um i think it's normal like i played a
lot of matches where i had a long break
between games but i think there's no
difference i think but maybe for android
there was but for me at least
there is not normally a big difference
well alireza there's this expression
better lucky than good
you are best lucky and good do you think
that your win against artemy of
yesterday
the way you won do you think that
actually was relief for you because
in a way maybe you shouldn't even have
made it to the semifinals do you think
you were kind of playing with a freer
mind
yeah of course i this is what i was
thinking about but when you get to the
game
like today again all the all the nerves
and everything will come back
somewhat suddenly so um
yeah i guess or tell me if it was just a
miracle of course and
um i looked at the match again and
i should have lost that hundred percent
but
i got very lucky i guess yeah i mean you
you gotta take your chances
and coming into this final we obviously
know you know what a beast of a bullet
player
andrew tang is and you've played it tons
of times did did you feel like maybe he
was a little bit off in his play today
because i felt like the score line that
you beat him by is probably
not how it usually goes or maybe it is i
don't know you tell it yeah normally
like it is in six months last six months
um then the result is not so surprising
i mean
in one minute i think i have this like
the advantage is clear
but in 30 seconds of course it's always
close but in one minute i was pretty
confident against andrew so
um it's not a surprise to me but maybe
well let me ask you a question about
that you said in the last six months
what have you done
differently in your online play because
you've won a bunch of title tuesdays
now you're the bullet chess champion
have you been doing anything differently
or
what's going right for you to be able to
rap no i think i just got better at
chess and
i mean
because i just win in the on positions
right you saw
um yeah so and also andrew's repertoire
is not
like pretty good with black and it's not
very
dangerous with white so yeah hey that
that definitely helps uh robert just
just get better at chess and
it'll definitely work alireza any uh any
plans for that ten thousand dollar first
uh prize i don't know probably um
no i don't know probably just going to
use it for streaming i guess i don't
know
yeah that's that's uh not a bad place to
put it i mean robert was actually
shouting you out
during the broadcast and it's a good
reminder for people you're streaming
over there
twitch.tv you know uh ali reza any any
plans for the streams in the future is
that a regular thing
yeah of course you're streaming like
everyday me and my brother in this
channel and we are doing a lot of good
things i guess
and we are also having youtube so we're
putting
the contents also there so it's pretty
good so
and they're going to continue of course
the
streaming and yeah well alareza congrats
again i think everyone is excited to
continue seeing your content and your
amazing amazing chess so huge
congratulations
it was a really great showing by you you
should be very proud of yourself
thank you see y'all reza thank you
and there you have it that is the bullet
chest champion alireza ferrugia
winning the final match by a score of 11
to five he actually
gave away the last couple games too
that's how dominant he was
and when you look at this bracket amman
you see all the great players that took
part
i it felt kind of right in the end that
alireza won but
that artemia met he said it himself it
was a miracle
that he made it through and how
different things could have been
yeah it's just uh comes with experience
though because artemia
he definitely had the lowest sample size
of games on chess.com of probably any
participant
uh in the field and you know he's maybe
not
as used to keeping track of the match
clock while he's playing there's just
all these things that factored into it
he he sort of just shows up and he's
insanely talented but
there's these smaller things sort of
more technical mistakes
uh unrelated to the chess that cost our
temmie of the match so
a little bit of experience there and no
fault to ali reza
you take those chances when they come to
you no fault
all strength and skill that was really
an exceptional showing by him
and well that is coming to our
conclusion the bullet just championship
but before we go
we'd like to show you our trade of the
day a segment presented by sig
and what a sequence this was yeah we
have to take you back to this moment
that
you know had robert and i just screaming
at everyone
in the chat here uh first of all talk
about trade of the day he grabs upon
here that is andrew tang with the black
pieces
and as soon as he did that this was him
saying i want the game to continue
he declined a repetition to make this
happen obviously he was down in the
match he needed to make a comeback
what's logical to follow up pawn to e6
and frusia starts pushing his pawn
to which andrew replied bishop takes f3
normally a good trade robber
because you want to double those pawns
but look at what happens next
i mean what a move not recapturing i say
this very often
just because someone took your piece
does not mean you have to take right
back
e7 great shot hitting the rook the rook
can't move because the rook and f4 would
lose defender otherwise the pawn
promotes
the bishop retreated and this is such a
great lesson that you do not
have to take a piece just because you
can queen
to e5 threatening me rather than taking
material
that is some great stuff it's beautiful
and you know just to even show a
potential finish
rook to f6 uh takes on f8 and takes on
g7 would be checkmate
so just a gorgeous finish by ferruja and
this is just
uh you know one of many ways that he
chose to finish off
uh his game so robert that is your trade
of the day
brought to you by sig and what a
sequence that was
and before we go we'd like to shout out
the event happening tomorrow
the bullet chess championship all-star
event also presented
by sig you see some of the faces taking
part in it
nemo you've got alexander botez anna
kremling maurice ashley
of course tanya sacha and others taking
part and amman you will have the call
with
donya neriditskiy so this tournament
didn't go down his way he'll be
commenting the action with you
i just i'm so excited to see that one
and how do we summarize
what just happened in the bcc well first
of all
it's nice to to be joined by daniel
always sad to see you go robert but
uh dania is a professional commentator
nice to get him back in the booth i
think i must have lost a
bullet championship you know four years
back when i
joined the booth and i haven't been back
since but definitely enjoyable
commentary what happened today first of
all hikaru
went down and in unexpected fashion he
had a three game lead against ali reza
that match was uh almost the final to me
that was the most exciting
thing that we saw today amazing comeback
by farouja
and and then he just put you know his
his skills
to work against andrew tang so i think
we were just privileged to have the best
four players
you know pretty much in the world right
now uh that actively play on chess.com
in this tournament and in the
semi-finals so uh really really exciting
day of chess obviously uh happy to uh
have the call with you robert and
looking forward to the all-star event
and uh to be joined with daniel
naradiski
and we did have two comeback kings in
the final but when all is said and done
only one could wear the crown that is
alireza farouza
your 2021 bullet chess champion he wins
a ten thousand dollar purse
he wins against ikaro nakamura in
dramatic fashion
as well artemia before that before
finally defeating tang
but credit to andrew tang as well
representing c9
and i'm sure that his esports organ
organization is proud of him but it is
ali raza fruga going in as the four seed
exiting
as the highest rated player in bullet
trust and
amman i have to thank you as always you
are such a good co-commentator
you provide the entertainment and the
education and i think everybody is
fortunate that you cover the action
thank you to our community who tunes in
every day
to watch us commentate and watch the
players go at it it really is
appreciated to the mods to our producers
everybody who makes this possible the
design team that
puts us great graphics for you so thank
you to everybody for your hard work and
amon you'll be back tomorrow but i'm
gonna have to bid everybody at june
yeah we'll see everybody back tomorrow
for the all-stars robert been an
absolute pleasure thank you everybody
for watching and make sure
to tune in tomorrow we'll see you guys
then
[Music]
you